Herzlich Willkommen zum Chaosradio Nummer 246. Heute mit einer unbekannten Stimme hier am Mikrofon. Mein Name ist Christoph Schrag. Ich springe ein für den lieben lieben Kollegen Markus Richter, der normalerweise hier zu hören ist. Der ist massivst verhindert. Grüße gehen raus an ihn. Und deswegen bin ich heute hier und senke den Nerdfaktor gewissermaßen und stelle die dümmsten Fragen überhaupt. Ich hoffe, ihr verzeiht es mir an dieser Stelle. Wir haben natürlich in diesem Chaosradio großartige Gäste heute. Der liebe Danimo ist da und unterstützt mich. Und dann einer unserer Gäste von der Gemeinschaft für Freiheitsrechte ist hier natürlich Ulf Bohrmeier. Hallo.
Ja, hallo, guten Abend.
Tachchen, denn das ist genau das Thema in diesem Chaosradio, in dieser Ausgabe. Wir beschäftigen uns mit Freiheitsrechten und die sind natürlich nach wie vor und immer wieder bedroht und zwar durch verschiedene Gesetze. Aber dazu kommen wir später noch genauer. Eigentlich hatten wir überlegt, wir steigen ein mit dem Polizeiaufgabengesetz in Bayern, dass er es immerhin geschafft hat, 10.000 Menschen auf die Straße zu bringen, obwohl es so kompliziert ist. 30.000 Menschen haben in München allein dagegen demonstriert, weil es übergriffig erscheint. Das ist aber jetzt noch übertroffen worden durch eine Entscheidung gestern Abend vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht, das gesagt hat, der Internetknoten in Frankfurt, korrigiert mich, wenn ich da Quatsch erzähle, Dekix darf weiter beschnüffelt werden vom Bundesnachrichtendienst. Ulf, das war zu erwarten oder wie?
Na, so weit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen, dass das zu erwarten war. Aber es war ganz sicher auch kein Selbstläufer, diese Klage des Dekix, unterstützt natürlich von Eko, dem Deutschen Internetverband. Interessant ist ja in der Entscheidung, dass das Bundesverwaltungsgericht einer der ganz zentralen Fragen eigentlich ausgewichen ist. Denn bei dieser Entscheidung geht es ja eben darum, ob Internetleitungen beim Dekix angezampft werden können und da geht es vor allem um Datenverkehr aus Deutschland heraus ins Ausland oder eben andersherum aus dem Ausland nach Deutschland hinein und sehr umstritten ist aber immer, wie es denn eigentlich ist mit der Anwendbarkeit unseres Fernmeldegeheimnisses aus dem Grundgesetz und diese Frage hat das Leipziger Gericht aber in diesem Fall gar nicht behandelt, sondern es hat ganz interessant entschieden, dass Dekix, also dieser Internetknoten, noch genauer die Firma, die diesen Internetknoten betreibt, dass die sich gar nicht auf das Fernmeldegeheimnis berufen kann, weil es ja um die Grundrechte geht der Menschen, die im Internet kommunizieren, nicht um die Grundrechte von Dekix in diesem Fall und deswegen ist, und das ist vielleicht das Überraschende daran, gar keine Entscheidung darüber getroffen worden, wie es denn steht um die Anwendbarkeit dieses Grundrechts, sondern es ist jedenfalls aus dieser Perspektive eher eine formale Entscheidung und die wesentliche inhaltliche Fragen eigentlich noch nicht klärt.
Zum Beispiel, also weil ich frage mich jetzt, wir reden ja heute über Freiheitsrechte, inwiefern sind die denn eigentlich eingeschränkt durch sozusagen das Datenabgreifen? Denn es geht glaube ich um Datenverkehr, der durch Frankfurt durchläuft, da geht es um wie überquert der internationale Grenzen, was ist davon nationaler Verkehr, wofür gilt überhaupt das Recht in Deutschland? Also inwiefern sind da Freiheitsrechte hier in Deutschland eingeschränkt durch dieses BND-Gesetz?
Da muss man so einen ganz kleinen Schritt zurücktreten und sich kurz fragen, was soll denn eigentlich dieses Fernmeldegeheimnis, was ist denn eigentlich die Idee dabei? Die Grundidee ist, wenn zwei Menschen durch den Park laufen, sich unterhalten, dann kann zunächst mal niemand mithören. Wenn man jetzt nicht einen dieser Menschen verwanzt hat, dann ist dieses Gespräch privat. Und da sind schlaue Menschen vor vielen Jahren schon auf die Idee gekommen, diese Privatheit sollte man eigentlich auch schützen, wenn die Menschen nicht zusammen durch den Park laufen, sondern wenn sie sich zum Beispiel über eine Telefonleitung unterhalten. Denn das Bedürfnis, sich vertrauensvoll austauschen zu können, ohne dass der Staat mitlauscht, das ist ja im Prinzip dasselbe, ob ich eben durch den Park gehe, ob ich irgendwo zusammen auf der Bank sitze oder ob ich vielleicht telefoniere. Deswegen gibt es dieses Fernmeldegeheimnis, das im Grunde die Privatheit der Kommunikation auch dann sicherstellen soll, wenn die Menschen sich nicht gegenüber sitzen. Finde ich persönlich eine zutiefst nachvollziehbare Idee. Dieses Fernmeldegeheimnis gilt grundsätzlich natürlich auch für die Kommunikation im Internet, gilt für alle Formen der Fernkommunikation, ob ich einen Brief schreibe, eine SMS schreibe oder eben telefoniere oder im Internet surfe. Und für den BND allerdings soll dieses Grundrecht im Prinzip nicht mehr gelten.
Beziehungsweise eingeschränkt werden oder kann man wirklich sagen, es gilt dann?
Ja, sagen wir so, es wird quasi nicht abgeschafft, aber es wird so weit eingeschränkt, dass man sagen muss, der BND ist von diesem Grundrecht quasi nicht mehr wirklich betroffen. Der kann also so das Internet überwachen, als würde es für ihn nicht gelten. Nicht innerhalb Deutschlands, aber eben für Datenverkehre, die im Ausland stattfinden, die sogenannte Ausland-Auslandüberwachung oder eben Datenverkehre, die deutsche Grenzen überschreiten. Und das ist der Fall, um den es hier in Leipzig ging. Und da ist seit langem umstritten, ob dieses Fernmeldegeheimnis, von dem ich gerade sprach, ob das eigentlich gilt für diese beiden Überwachungsformen des BND. Der BND sagt nein, im Ausland und für Ausländer gilt es zunächst mal gar nicht. Da steht der BND weitgehend alleine. Gibt es nur ganz wenige Rechtsexperten, die das ebenso sehen. Aber diese spannende Frage hätte vielleicht auch das Bundesverwaltungsgericht sich näher anschauen können. Aber das, wie gesagt, hat es gar nicht getan, aber aus seiner Sicht auch konsequent, weil es nämlich gesagt hat, das mag ja sein, dass dieses Grundrecht gilt. Brauchen wir aber nicht zu entscheiden, denn jedenfalls Dekix als Betreiber dieses Knotens kann sich nicht auf Grundrechte berufen, die die Privathat der Menschen schützt, die über diesen Inhaltknoten kommen.
Also das war eigentlich Teil der Frage. Danimo, du hattest einen Einwurf.
Was halt noch ganz interessant ist, weil Ulf das gerade ausgeführt hat mit was ist Ausland, Ausland und so, die Art und Weise, wie sich das der BND da zurecht definiert hat und entsprechend angibt Filter zu verwenden, ist ja eigentlich auch ganz spannend, weil bei der klassischen Telefonie, da hat man irgendwie von der Internationalen Telekommunikationsunion irgendwie diese Vorwahlen, Auslandsvorwahlen, also plus 49 für Deutschland, da kann man noch argumentieren, okay, wenn jetzt jemand über Deutschland irgendwie nicht von plus 49 irgendwas anruft oder nach plus 49, dann wird das wohl Ausland, Ausland sein, das ist, kann man so argumentieren. Was jetzt spannend ist, wie argumentierst du das für Internetverkehr und die Aussage, die da von Seiten des BND kam, korrigiere mich, oder wenn ich das falsch in Erinnerung habe, war, dass sie gesagt haben, ja also alles, was Punkt.de ist, das gucken wir uns nicht an und das ist natürlich auf so vielen Ebenen absurd. A, wer hat nicht irgendwie eine gmail.com-Adresse und sitzt halt trotzdem in Deutschland? Wie viele Firmen haben einfach irgendwie eine.com-Adresse, obwohl sie eine deutsche Firma sind? Also das ist alleine schon dieses Konstrukt, das ist auf so vielen Ebenen einfach absurd. Deswegen finde ich das halt auch schade, dass wir auf diese Ebene gar nicht gekommen sind.
Das heißt also Datenverkehr, korrigiere mich, wenn das falsch ist, kann man gar nicht national über die Nationengrenzen gehen.
So wie das Internet funktioniert eben nicht. Also die ganze Idee an Knoten wie diesem Dezix und überhaupt diesem Internet ist ja, man verschaltet verschiedene Netze, der Fachbegriff da ist autonomes System und sorgt dafür, dass die möglichst problemlos Datenpakete austauschen können. Und an der Stelle ist halt schon mal gesagt, ich weiß nicht, was die Firmen aus ihrem autonomen System quasi an Daten rausführen und woher die kommen. Das ist einfach, oder ob sie quasi ihr Netz nicht nur zur Verfügung stellen, um Verkehr aus anderen Netzen quasi weiter zu transportieren.
Wir sind hier schon mega eingestiegen in dieses Thema. Es soll eigentlich um Freiheitsrechte gehen heute. Das ist die große Überschrift, deswegen sind eigentlich auch zwei Gäste geladen hier von der Gemeinschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Die werden wir genau nochmal später erklären, was sie genau machen, wenn nämlich auch Nora Markath noch bei uns ist, zusammen mit Ulf Burmais. Sie ist uns allerdings dann zugeschaltet über Skype. Ab halb werden wir uns also noch mal genauer mit Freiheitsrechten und der GFF beschäftigen. Ihr seid natürlich auch herzlich aufgerufen anzurufen. Das ist ja schließlich hier ein Blumen. 031 77 97 110 ist wie immer die Nummer. Wenn ihr Fragen habt, beispielsweise zu der Entscheidung vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht gestern, was das eigentlich für eure Internetkommunikation heißt, denn ich meine der Großteil der Daten wird hier in Deutschland auf jeden Fall über diesen Frankfurter Knoten abgewickelt. Das ist wohl der weltweit größte Internetknoten, sagt zumindest die Betreiberfirma über ihn selbst. Also wenn ihr dazu Fragen habt, ruft an, 931 70 97 110. Außerdem werden wir später noch sprechen über das bayerische Polizeiaufgabengesetz. Wir werden auch noch zu sprechen haben über den sogenannten Datenhehlerei-Paragrafen, der es Whistleblowern hier in Deutschland, also Menschen, die möglicherweise etwas wissen, was die Allgemeinheit interessiert. Sie dürfen es aber eigentlich nicht verraten. Macht denen das Leben schwer und das möglicherweise einfach durch eine Panne beim Gesetz zu schreiben. Die waren nämlich gar nicht gemeint, die Whistleblowern, die man das Leben schwer machen wollte, sondern es ging um das illegale Verhehlen von Kreditkartendaten beispielsweise. Aber da wurde sozusagen das Kind mit dem Bade ausgegossen und nun stehen möglicherweise Whistleblower vor schweren Zeiten hier in Deutschland. All diesen Fragen ruft an, Notdater 1 70 97 110 hier im Blumen zum Chaosradio. Ulf, wie müsste es denn jetzt eigentlich weitergehen, wenn das über das zentrale Thema bei DECIX gar nicht entschieden wurde? Nämlich was ist mit meinen Grundrechten, wie werden die eingeschränkt, wenn mein Datenverkehr über diesen Internetknoten läuft?
Ja, zunächst mal wird man jetzt mal abwarten müssen, wie denn die schriftlichen Urteilsgründe ausfallen. Bislang gibt es ja nur eine Pressemitteilung des Bundesverwaltungsgerichts, die zwar schon relativ konkret ist, aber rechtlich kann man dieses Urteil eigentlich erst bewerten, wenn man auch tatsächlich die ausformulierten Gründe gelesen hat. Und dann wird die Betreiberfirma vom DECIX sich überlegen, was sie als nächstes tut. Es gibt also kein ordentliches Rechtsmittel mehr. Der nächste Schritt wäre dann die Verfassungsbeschwerde zum Bundesverfassungsgericht. Da könnte man durchaus mal die Frage eben zur Diskussion stellen, ob denn nicht ein Betreiber einer Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur sich durchaus auf die Grundrechte auch seiner Kundinnen und Kunden berufen kann, denn ganz ehrlich, sonst kann dieses Grundrecht in einer solchen Konstellation normalerweise niemand rügen, denn die Menschen, um deren Daten es geht, und das sind wir alle interessanterweise, die erfahren ja gar nicht so richtig, wenn ihre Daten konkret betroffen sind. Das heißt also, wenn nicht die Betreiberfirma, die diese Anordnung bekommt, jetzt bitte mal die Leitung anzuzapfen, wenn diese Betreiberfirma das nicht angreifen kann vor Gericht, dann entsteht im Grunde eine Rechtsschutzlücke und das ist eine Situation, die das Bundesverfassungsgericht normalerweise vermeidet. Also es gibt ja in Deutschland so eine sogenannte Rechtsschutzgarantie. Man soll eigentlich gegen das gesamte Handeln der Verwaltung irgendwie klagen können und eine Situation, wie sie jetzt hier eingetreten ist, würde dazu führen, dass man da, dass eigentlich niemand mehr klagen kann so richtig und da denke ich, kann man jedenfalls mit einiger Aussicht auf Erfolg noch mal das Bundesverfassungsgericht fragen, ob das denn so richtig sein kann.
Wenn ich das selber gar nicht erfahre und möglicherweise selber meine Daten auch gar nicht betroffen sind und der DECIX das jetzt auch gar nicht mir mitteilt oder muss er das, der Knoten?
Nein, das ist vielleicht ganz interessant, diese Frage kurz mal vor die Klammer zu ziehen, um welche Daten geht es denn eigentlich? Es gibt ja ganz verschiedene Formen von Überwachung der Telekommunikation. Wenn jetzt jemand zum Beispiel im Verdacht steht, ein Drogendealer zu sein, dann kann auch ein Richter anordnen, dass dessen Handy zum Beispiel angezapft wird, und dann muss ich sagen, ist das rechtsstaatlich im Prinzip auch in Ordnung. Dass man also zur Aufklärung eines schweren Straftatverdachts ein Handy anzapft oder eine Telefonleitung, das ist aus meiner Sicht rechtsstaatlich in Ordnung. Da muss man dann ein bestimmtes Verfahren einhalten, aber das kann in Ordnung sein. Die Situation beim DECAX ist eine völlig andere. Es geht nämlich nicht um die gezielte Überwachung von Verdächtigen, sondern es geht um die generelle Überwachung des kompletten Datenverkehrs, der durch bestimmte Leitungen fließt. Das heißt also ohne jeden Verdacht, einfach nur um zu schauen, was da sich Menschen so schreiben und das ist das, was Constanze Kurz immer so schön die großen Datenstaubsauger nennt. Da wird einfach alles abgeschneuchelt, was über diese Leitung läuft und deswegen habe ich eben gesagt, das Fernmeldegeheimnis gilt für den BND in der Praxis nicht mehr, weil er eben nicht mehr argumentieren muss, hey, wir haben ja einen Verdacht gegen einen Gefährder zum Beispiel, sondern der kann einfach sagen, uns interessiert diese Leitung und dann wird die komplette Leitung ausgeleitet. Und das finde ich, ist schon jedenfalls eine extrem drastische Einschränkung des Fernmeldegeheimnisses, wo man sich fragen kann, was bleibt von diesem Grundrecht noch übrig?
Was passiert denn mit den Daten eigentlich? Warum ist der BND so interessiert an diesen Daten? Was versuchen die da zusammenzusetzen? Sie müssen ja dann auch irgendetwas damit zu tun. Das sind ja unendlich viele Datenströme, die da rüberlaufen. Also was machen die damit?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, die sich auch viele kluge Menschen im sogenannten NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss natürlich gestellt haben, wo man versucht hat, das mal rauszufinden. Das ist alles natürlich ganz furchtbar geheim, das heißt also richtig genau weiß das eigentlich niemand außerhalb des BND, was mit diesen Daten geschieht. Es gibt jedenfalls Ansätze, die sich zum Beispiel auch aus dem BND-Gesetz ergeben, was man mit diesen Daten machen kann oder aus dem sogenannten G10. Die Daten werden wohl nicht komplett gespeichert, das kann man jedenfalls hoffen, dass sie nicht komplett gespeichert werden oder nur für eine bestimmte Zeit und werden ausgewertet, indem man nach bestimmten Stichworten sucht. Also die brümmten Selektoren, die auch in der öffentlichen Diskussion schon eine große Rolle gespielt haben.
Beim NSA Skandal damals.
Beim NSA Skandal, genau. Und dann wird eben nach diesen Selektoren nach bestimmten Stichworten oder zum Beispiel nach Telefonnummern gesucht, um daraus Erkenntnis zu gewinnen. Aber was der BND da ganz genau macht, weiß man nicht. Und außerdem, neben dieser Selektoren-Suche gibt es dann noch die Möglichkeit einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung im Grunde, wo also jedenfalls die Tatsache, welche Personen oder welche Rufnummer miteinander kommuniziert haben, noch wesentlich weitergehend gespeichert wird. Also der sogenannte Full-Take, die gesamten Daten dürfen normalerweise nur begrenzt gespeichert werden, aber diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung geht deutlich länger. Da kann man, also quasi wer hat mit wem kommuniziert, das darf oder wer hat wem eine E-Mail geschrieben, das darf deutlich länger gespeichert werden.
Ich finde es immer so schwer auch auszumachen, wer jetzt eigentlich genau der Geschädigte ist an der Stelle. Klar, die DECICS fühlt sich übergangen, die wird dazu gezwungen, irgendwie Daten öffentlich zu machen oder zumindest weiterzugeben, die eigentlich, für die sie sozusagen ihre Obhut bekommen hat von uns. Gewissermaßen, da kann man schon das klar sagen, aber zu welchem Zeitpunkt bin ich ein Geschädigter und was ist der Schaden sozusagen? Oder wer sind besonders betroffene Personengruppen, die das eben massiv interessieren müssten?
Das ist eben sehr schwer zu sagen, wie man konkret geschädigt ist. Es ist, weil der BND ja keine Rechtschaft legt. Man weiß einfach gar nicht, was mit diesen Daten passiert, was die konkret dann für Auswirkungen haben. Was man aber auf jeden Fall eben sich klar machen muss, ist, dass es unter Geltung dieser Gesetze jedenfalls gegenüber dem BND keine geheime Kommunikation mehr gibt. Und der BND, das weiß man auch, arbeitet mit anderen sogenannten befreundeten Diensten zusammen. Da werden Daten ausgetauscht, Daten weitergegeben. Und auf diese Art und Weise ist dann auch für den BND häufig gar nicht mehr klar, wer denn jetzt eigentlich diese Daten bekommen hat. Und spannend wird es zum Beispiel, wenn man mal an Journalistinnen und Journalisten denkt, die ja häufig mit ihren Quellen geheim kommunizieren müssen. Weil diese Quellen vielleicht in ihrem Land von Geheimdiensten bedroht werden oder auch von Kriminellen bedroht werden, die wiederum dann mit korrupten Beamten zusammenarbeiten, mit anderen Worten. Es gibt durchaus Menschen, die ein großes Interesse daran haben, dass sie geheim mit Journalistinnen und Journalisten kommunizieren können, Quellen. Und wenn die wiederum dann damit rechnen müssen, dass der BND und andere Geheimdienste erfahren, mit wem sie so kommunizieren, dann ist das natürlich für diese Menschen mit einer großen Einschüchterung verbunden. Und das wiederum macht dann unter Umständen Recherche schwieriger.
Vielleicht die Frage mal an Danimo, das ist eine eher technische Geschichte. Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, das irgendwie zu umgehen? Diese Internetknoten dann sehr wahrscheinlich oder Kryptographie oder weißt der Gäste, was wenn man jetzt wirklich sagt, okay, ich weiß jetzt, dass die Entscheidung ist so und so gefallen, damit muss ich mich jetzt erstmal abfinden, bis da vielleicht gegen geklagt wird. Also meine Daten, wenn ich Google benutze, wenn ich Facebook benutze, wenn ich Spotify benutze, das sind wirklich alle großen, werden über diesen Frankfurter Knoten abgewickelt. Ich muss mich damit abfinden, das wird also abgeschöpft. Wenn ich das nicht will, habe ich eine Möglichkeit?
Ja, also was heißt, also wenn ich nicht abgeschöpft werden will, wird es schwierig, weil ich kann mich persönlich nicht entscheiden, wie meine Daten geroutet werden. Das ist einfach eine Entscheidung. Ich kippe meine Daten bei meinem Internetanbieter ein und der sorgt dann dafür, dass die ins Ziel kommen. Wie ist prinzipbedingt einfach nicht zu sagen, aus meiner Warte, das sollte auch nicht sein, was aber klar ist, Frankfurt ist halt ein Knoten. Ja, es gibt Alternativen, die gibt es auch im Ausland. Aber gerade da muss man sich halt fragen, ist der BND denn der einzige Geheimdienst, der Begehrlichkeiten hat? Und das kann man mit Sicherheit verneinen. Und deswegen, das hast du eben schon angesprochen, die einzige Möglichkeit, die man da hat, ist in einer Form Verschlüsselung anzuwenden. Bei Webseiten ist es insofern einfach, als dass die mittlerweile eigentlich alle verschlüsselt sind. Da haben wir jetzt mittlerweile die Leier von der Datenschutzgrundverordnung, kann eigentlich keiner mehr hören. Aber genau die sorgt tatsächlich dafür, dass gerade die letzten Krypto-Muffel jetzt irgendwie anfangen, ihre Webseiten mit TLS, also auf HTTPS-Basis, auszustatten und umzurüsten.
Also sozusagen, die verschlüsselte Seite wird zum Standard jetzt nicht, ne?
Genau, und das ist ganz interessant. Da war auch heute eine Meldung, die wir gleich noch hören werden in den Nerdnews, die Browser-Anbieter hören auf zu sagen, pass mal auf, die Seite ist gesichert, sondern warnen dich explizit oder beginnen jetzt zu warnen in dem Moment, wo eine Seite nicht mehr gesichert ist. Und das ist zumindest für das Web-Surfen eigentlich jetzt mittlerweile das, was normal ist. Und das ist auch gut so.
Das heißt, den Content hier, den kann aber auch der BND nicht lesen, weil es verschlüsselt ist oder sehe ich das falsch?
Zumindest über diesen Weg nicht.
Sondern?
Ich möchte jetzt hier, also da kann sich jetzt jeder seinen eigenen Aluhut aufziehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Ulf da noch irgendwelche Sachen...
Na, da gibt es natürlich auch Hintertüren. Das Wichtigste stark von in dem Zusammenhang sind die Staatstrojaner. Denn wenn man sich in einen Rechner rein hackt, dann hilft die Verschlüsselung auf der Leitung natürlich auch nichts mehr. Da kommen wir vielleicht noch später dazu.
Das ist ein PRG und Co, ne?
Ja, das PRG in Bayern hat auch eine Rechtsgrundlage für Staatsstrojaner. Aber die wichtigsten Staatsstrojaner-Grundlagen finden sich sonst im BKA-Gesetz und in der Strafbezepsordnung und so. Da kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch mal zu, denn das sind ja auch Verfahren der GFF. Ja, das ist natürlich eine Lücke und dann weiß man ja nie, ob es nicht vielleicht doch unerkannte Sicherheitslücken gibt in Verschlüsselungsprotokollen, nicht? Da will ich jetzt aber auch nicht orakelen. Bislang sieht es nur aus, als wenn eine sauber umgesetzte TLS mit den richtigen Parametern schon noch sicher ist. Aber letztlich weiß man es nie.
Sauber umgesetzte TLS, da muss ich kurz einhaken.
TLS ist einfach das Protokoll, was man hernimmt, um irgendeinen Inhalt, der vorher quasi unverschlüsselt war, dann zu sichern. Und quasi so eine Zwischenschicht, die den unverschlüsslichen Verkehr einpackt und quasi für solche Leute, die einfach mal sich an die Glasfaser hängen und alles abschnorcheln, quasi nicht verständlich macht.
Okay, wir reden hier das große Überthema Freiheitsrechte, was heute sozusagen ganz aktuell ist mit der Entscheidung vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht zu sagen. Der große Internetknoten in Frankfurt, wo unser aller Internetkommunikationen drüber geleitet wird, der größte weltweit, der kann sich nicht dagegen wehren, dass der Bundesnachrichtendienst Daten von ihm einfach abschöpft, das heißt, er muss seine Daten ausleiten, wenn der BND das gerne hätte. Wir haben versucht, herauszuarbeiten, wie das in unserer aller Freiheit im Grunde eingreift und das ist eben auch das große Thema der GFF, der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Hier zu Gast ist Ulf Burmeier, den habt ihr reden gehört, der wird uns auch noch die nächsten anderthalb Stunden begleiten und dann werden wir auch nochmal genauer über die Arbeit von der GFF sprechen, denn sie hat sich zum Ziel gesetzt, die Freiheitsrechte mittels gut aufgebauter Fälle und Kläger stellvertretend für uns alle zu verteidigen und das an verschiedenen Fronten. Wie das Ganze funktioniert, welche Fälle sie momentan streiten, was das alles mit uns zu tun hat, das erfahren wir jetzt noch im Laufe der Sendung. Wenn ihr Fragen habt zu den Themen, die wir hier anschneiden, also beispielsweise das BND-Gesetz, das BKA-Gesetz ist hier auch noch gerade gefallener, ist immer die Rede von der drohenden Gefahr, die sozusagen alles schwammig macht und scheinbar alles möglich zu machen scheint, was Überwachung angeht oder Polizeieingriff oder wenn es beispielsweise ums Polizeiaufgabengesetz in Bayern geht, dann ruft an, 031 70 97 110. Eine letzte Frage noch, bevor wir so langsam in die Nachrichten rübergehen. Wenn jetzt also die Datenkommunikation abgeschöpft wird über Frankfurt und diese Entscheidung jetzt erstmal noch nichts gebracht hat, wie könnte beispielsweise das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagen, das geht aber nicht, worauf müssten die sich berufen, wenn man das jetzt vor das Verfassungsgerichte bringen will? Wie würdet ihr das beispielsweise als GFF machen, so ein Fall?
Also der konkrete Fall, der jetzt in Leipzig gerade entschieden wurde, man zu den?
Ja, ich meine eher, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, Dekix kann nicht auf sein eigenes Grundrecht hier klagen, aber wie machen wir weiter? Wie würdet ihr so einen Fall aufziehen? Ihr sprecht sozusagen auf eurer Homepage davon, ihr sucht einen guten Kläger. Wäre das irgendwie Carl Otto oder ich?
Also ich finde zum Beispiel, ich kenne das schriftliche Urteil noch nicht, das muss man immer sagen, muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, aber ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass es Sinn macht, einfach dieses Leipziger Urteil tatsächlich vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht anzugreifen. Wenn ich die Medien richtig verstanden habe, hat Eko als Träger vom Dekix das ja auch schon angekündigt, dass sie den Gang nach Karlsruhe jedenfalls prüfen und das macht aus meiner Sicht durchaus Sinn, denn wie gesagt, so wie die Leipziger Bundesverwaltungsrichter das Grundrecht, also das Fernwändegeheimnis jetzt ausgelegt haben, kann sich im Ergebnis niemand mehr darauf berufen, Dekix nicht, weil sie zwar erfahren von der Anordnung, die Leitung zu überwachen, aber eben angeblich sich nicht darauf berufen können und die Menschen, um deren Daten es geht, können sich einfach rein praktisch nicht so richtig darauf berufen, weil sie gar nicht mitbekommen, dass ihre Daten tatsächlich angegriffen wurden. Das heißt, dann entsteht so eine Rechtsschutzlücke und da könnte es aus meiner Sicht sehr gut sein, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, nein, so kann es nicht gehen. Und da gibt es auch durchaus, sagen wir mal, entfernt vergleichbare Fälle. Beispielsweise können sich auch Rundfunksender und Rundfunkanstalten ja durchaus auf die Rundfunkfreiheit berufen zum Beispiel. Und da wird häufig auch gesagt, dass sie sich, dass sie neben ihren eigenen Grundrechten auch eine grundrechtsdienende Funktion wahrnehmen, eben auch für die Menschen, die dann letztlich von der Rundfunkfreiheit profitieren. Und insofern könnte ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, nein auch Fernmeldedienstleister, Telekommunikationsdienstleister haben eine grundrechtsdienende Funktion für die Menschen, die ihnen Daten anvertrauen zum sicheren Transport, zum Beispiel im Internet. Das wäre rechtsdogmatisch, also nichts völlig Neues, das könnte man sich vorstellen und es würde verhindern, dass an dieser Stelle ein Rechtsschutzlücke eintritt. Aber ich würde jetzt nicht so weit gehen zu sagen, das wird das Bundesverfassungsgericht auf jeden Fall machen, das ist ein schwieriger Fall. Das muss man sehr gut machen und da würde ich aber darauf vertrauen, dass EKO da dann einfach eine gute Verfassungsbeschwerde erheben lässt.
Und da können Sie auch weiter kligga bleiben, also da muss man jetzt nicht irgendjemanden suchen, der ist über Grundrechte vermeintlich eingeschränkt worden.
Nee, da kann jetzt quasi niemand mehr drauf springen auf dieses Verfahren, denn das ist ja jetzt in erster und letzter Instanz in Leipzig schon entschieden. Das ist jetzt diese eine Klage, die man aber jetzt eben noch mit einer Verfassungsbeschwerde weiter verfolgen kann.
Okay, mehr zur Arbeit von der GFF gleich nach den Nachrichten. Vor den Nachrichten machen wir noch einen Titel von der Heldin der Wahrheit. Das ist in diesem Fall Lena Störfaktor von ihrem neuen Album Bly.
Natürlich behauptet jedes Festival von sich, das beste, schönste und überhaupt allergeilste zu sein. Aber aufgepasst, die allergeilsten Festivals sind nur echt allergeilst mit dem feiergeprüften, offiziellen, hammerkrassen heißen Fritz & Festivals Goethe-Siegel-Stempel.
Fritz & Festivals.
Entschuldigung.
Cole, Trettmann und Casper. Das Helene Beach mit Savas und Sido, 187 Straßenbande und Paul Kalkbrenner. Das Lollapalooza Berlin mit den Wombats, Kaigo und Imagine Dragons.
Solang es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall wo es Karten gibt.
Von Feierabruppen, Festival Fritzen geprüft, für oberkrass nice befunden.
Demba Naby, Sänger in der Band Seed und auch bekannt unter den Namen ihr oder Bounce Sound ist tot. Das teilte sein Anwalt mit. Die genauen Umstände sind noch unklar. Auf der Facebook-Seite von Seed hieß es schlicht, wir trauern um unseren Freund und Sänger. Naby wurde 1972 in Berlin Buch geboren. Vor einem Monat hatte Seed eine Tour für Herbst 2019 angekündigt. Viele Konzerte waren sehr schnell ausverkauft. In Italien steht nach wochenlangen Verhandlungen eine neue Regierung. Präsident Mattarella teilte Giuseppe Conte den Regierungsauftrag, sagte ein Sprecher. Die Vereidigung soll morgen in Rom stattfinden. Conte wird von der populistischen 5-Sterne-Bewegung und der rechten Lega unterstützt. Ein erster Anlauf zur Regierungsbildung war gescheitert, nachdem Mattarella einen eurokritischen Kandidaten für einen Ministerposten abgelehnt hatte. Bundesaußenminister Maas hat die Zollentscheidung der USA kritisiert. Sie sei nicht nachvollziehbar. Maas warb für eine geschlossene Antwort der Europäer, warnte aber auch davor, die Lage eskalieren zu lassen. US-Handelsminister Ross hat es zuvor mitgeteilt, dass neue Zölle auf Stahl und Aluminium ab morgen auch für die EU gelten. Seit heute dürfen in Hamburg bestimmte Dieselfahrzeuge nicht mehr fahren. Es ist das erste Mal, dass es eine solche Regelung gibt. Sie betreffen zwei Straßen in Hamburg und sollen helfen, die hohe Stickoxidbelastung an den Strecken zu senken. Umweltorganisationen kritisieren, dass die Maßnahme nur Symbolpolitik sei. Es reiche nicht nur, ein paar hundert Meter Straße ein bisschen weniger dreckig zu machen, hieß es von Greenpeace. Die aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin, Teppelhof 26, Friedrichshain 28, Frankfurt Oder 22, Neuglobso und Ludwigsfelde 24 und Lindenberg 25 Grad. Leichte Wolken und größtenteils trocken, so wird die Nacht. Nur im Süden und Westen kann es einzelne Schauer und Gewitter geben. Die Tiefswerte liegen bei 15 bis 20 Grad. Der Tag startet dann mit viel Sonne. Im Verlauf bilden sich dann aber auch Quellwolken, die teils kräftige Schauer und Gewitter mitbringen. Dazu wird es sehr warm mit 30 bis 34 Grad. Und so bleibt es dann auch die nächsten Tage schwül und heiß mit Gewittern zwischendurch. Auf der A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Spreeau zwischen Königswusterhausen und Niederlehme Behinderungen wegen Straßenschäden und Stadtverkehr Berlin auf der B96 Oranienburger Chaussee zwischen Schwarzgittelweg in Frohnau und Berliner Stadtgrenze Vollsperrung in beiden Richtungen wegen Fahrbahnerneuerung bis morgen früh um 6. Wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt.
Und an dieser Stelle kommen natürlich auch noch die NerdNews zum Einsatz. Wir sind hier im Chaosradio, Nummer 246 ist das. Und Bene Wenk liest für uns heute die NerdNews.
Europäischer Datenschutz wird gestärkt. Die Datenschutzgrundverordnung ist in der EU in Kraft getreten. Sie regelt die Verarbeitung personenbezogener Daten durch Privatpersonen, Unternehmen und öffentliche Stellen. Gleichzeitig gewährleistet sie den freien Datenverkehr am europäischen Binnenmarkt. Verstöße können mit empfindlichen Bußgeldstrafen bestraft werden. Der von Reporter ohne Grenzen auf der Republik her vorgestellte Bitte nicht durchleuchten Generator zeigt Wirkung. Über 2000 Bundesbürger nutzten den Generator, um die Herausnahme ihrer Daten aus der Fährers-Datei zu fordern. Im letzten Jahr hatte das Bundesverwaltungsgericht festgestellt, dass die Datenbank zur Verbindungsdatenanalyse gegengeltendes Recht verstößt. Der BND erklärte, dass die Datenbank jetzt rechtskonform betrieben werde. Weitere Verfahren gegen die Datensammlungen des BND sind vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht noch anhängig. Zum Beispiel die G10-Überwachungsanordnungen am DECIX. Sowohl die Schufa als auch andere Auskunftsteiln zahlen die Gutachten selbst, nachdem die Datenschutzbehörden sie kontrollieren sollen. Nach Berichten des Bayerischen Rundfunks verlassen sich die Datenschutzbehörden auf die Korrektheit der Gutachten, auch weil ihnen die nötigen Mittel fehlen, um eigene Gutachten in Auftrag zu geben. In den Gutachten werden die Berechnungsverfahren überprüft, nach denen die Scoring-Werte ermittelt werden. Die Initiative Open Schufa hat vor kurzem begonnen, die Verfahren hinter dem Schufa-Scoring zu entschlüsseln. Dafür gab es in einem Crowdfunding über 40.000 Euro von Unterstützern.
Die Neure News von Benevenk, heute im Chaosradio Nr.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des AirBB.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal fritz.de slash tips.
Ach, das geht ja gut durch hier. Also ich muss da gleich noch zur Erklärung sagen, hier sitzt ja jemand am Chaosradio, der das noch nie gemacht hat, als wäre es meine erste Sendung. Christoph Schrag ist mein Name. Hallo, ich springe ein für Markus Richter und sitze hier sozusagen vor einem Sendeablauf, den ich gar nicht gewohnt bin. Das ist nur zu meiner Entschuldigung für Leute, für die regelmäßigen Hörer vom Chaosradio, aber an anderen versuche ich gar nicht mehr, das hier zu erklären. Wir sind beim Chaosradio Nr. 246. Wir sprechen heute über Freiheitsrechte und das tun wir mit Gästen, und zwar Ulf Burmeier. Ihr habt ihn schon gehört, gerade in der ersten halben Stunde. Er ist von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte und gleich ist er uns auch noch zugeschaltet über Skype. Seine Kollegin Nora Markath, ebenfalls von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Das klappt. Und hallo, Ulf. Hallo. Die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte verteidigt die Grund- und Menschenrechte in klug ausgewählten und sorgfältig vorbereiteten Fällen. So was, was wir gerade besprochen haben, die DECICS, wäre das was für euch?
Ja, klar. Also grundsätzlich ist das natürlich ein Fall, den würden wir uns angucken. Also das ist, wir prüfen unsere Fälle immer sehr genau. Wir gucken auch, was schaffen wir insgesamt. Aber grundsätzlich, wenn wir sehen, dass hier so ein wirklich ein strukturelles Problem liegt und dass das auch ein Fall ist, der über den Einzelfall hinausweist, also der wirklich so für noch mal so Grundfragen zur Klärung bringen könnte, dann ist das grundsätzlich auch ein Fall für uns. Also das gucken wir uns immer sehr genau an und sehen auch, dass wir, was wir da leisten können, was wir beitragen können. Also das wäre schon grundsätzlich was für uns, ja.
Seit wann gibt es die GFF und worum ging es im Gründungs- Was war der Gründungsanlass dafür?
Es gibt natürlich ein Gründungsmythos. Unser Gründungsmythos ist, auf dem Oranienplatz in Berlin saßen wir, nachdem Ulf aus New York wiedergekommen ist, ich war das Jahr davor, und er kam wieder und hatte sich die ganzen NGOs in den USA angeguckt, also die American Civil Liberties Union, ACLU, aber auch die Electronic Quantum Foundation, die EFF, und hatte so ein bisschen geguckt, wie arbeiten die und können wir das nicht vielleicht auch in Deutschland machen, hatte dann hier in Deutschland mal ein paar befreundete NGOs gefragt, ob die nicht vielleicht auch mal so ein bisschen in Richtung Datenschutz was machen wollen. Die sagten alle, ja super, das müsste mal jemand machen, aber nicht hier. Und dann dachte sich der Ulf irgendwie, vielleicht müssen wir das auch einfach selber machen, und dann saßen wir da so zusammen, sagte er, sag mal, würdest du da eigentlich mitmachen? Und was mich daran überzeugt hat oder deswegen ich das ein wichtiges Thema finde, ist, ich bin ja an der Uni beschäftigt, dass mir wichtig ist, dass Recht eben nicht nur auf dem Papier steht, sondern auch in die Praxis wird, das ist für mich schon lange ein Thema. Und dass ich eben denke, es gibt sowas einfach bisher in Deutschland nicht. Also dass es eine Organisation gibt, die jetzt nicht nur politische Arbeit macht im Bereich des Schutzes der Freiheitsrechte, sondern die eben auch die Kapazität und die Expertise hat dann wirklich auch Fälle mal vor Bericht zu bringen und da langfristig dran zu bleiben. Also jetzt nicht mal so einen Fall zu machen, sondern eben zu sagen, wir können da ein paar Jahre dran bleiben und wir machen parallel auch weitere Fälle. Und da denke ich, ist wirklich, das gab es bisher nicht und das können wir und das haben wir uns dann vorgenommen. Und das läuft jetzt seit 2015 haben wir es gegründet, 2016 sind wir in die Öffentlichkeit gegangen und seitdem läuft es ziemlich gut für mich.
Jetzt seid ihr ja ohnehin schon eigentlich ganz gut beschäftigt, oder? Den Ulf Burmeier, den kennen wir von Lage der Nationen, ein Podcast, den er auch schon so irgendwie nebenbei macht. Dazu Richter, du bist Professorin in Hamburg für öffentliches Recht, forscht nebenher noch in sozusagen Rechtsvergleichung international, Refugee Law Center steht da auch noch auf dem Zettel. Wenn man sich sowas aufhalts, also die Verteidigung von Freiheitsrechten, ist das nicht eigentlich ohnehin schon ein Fulltime-Job?
Na ja, eigentlich natürlich schon, klar. Wir machen das aber natürlich jetzt im Vorstand. Trotzdem, hast du ja gerade gesagt, auch ehrenamtlich. Also die ganzen Grundentscheidungen und die Betreuung der Fälle, das machen wir neben unseren Vollzeit-Jobs, einfach weil wir davon überzeugt sind, dass das wichtig ist. Wir haben aber inzwischen auch Leute einstellen können. Also wir haben sehr auch daran gearbeitet, dass wir uns mit einer dauerhaften Finanzierung aufstellen. Und das heißt, wir haben inzwischen einen Anwalt eingestellt, wir haben jemanden, der bei uns die Geschäftsführung macht, wir haben jemanden für die Presse, wir haben jetzt eine Fundraiserin, sogar die das auch richtig professionell dann für uns übernimmt. Weil das ist natürlich, je mehr da parallel läuft, desto mehr wissen wir auch Sachen professionalisieren. Aber ja, das sind Sachen, wofür wir alle brennen. Und insofern geben wir da auch gerne unsere Freizeit für ihnen.
Was sind das momentan für Fälle, die ihr gerade bearbeitet? Also wo seht ihr die Freiheit bedroht? Wessen Freiheit ist das und was sind das für Fälle?
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, inzwischen schon ein relativ großes Portfolio, was wir da haben. Also ihr habt jetzt vorhin schon so ein bisschen über Datenschutzfragen gesprochen, das sind wichtige Themen für uns. Weil auch gerade da aus unserer Sicht eben so ein bisschen vielleicht auch die Sensibilität in der Bevölkerung nachgelassen hat. Wenn man das jetzt mal so vergleicht mit der Atmosphäre damals um den großen Lauschangriff, wo das die große Aufregung war, ist das irgendwie heute so ein bisschen zur Normalität geworden. Also das ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Aber wir machen die Grund- und Menschenrechte, die sind für uns schon in der vollen Breite wichtig. Und wir heißen ja Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Das heißt, es geht schon uns auch darum, dass man so den gesellschaftlichen Raum frei hält und auch so, sag ich mal, es Leuten ermöglicht, sich ohne Angst politisch zu engagieren und auch Musselblower zu schützen zum Beispiel. Aber was uns schon auch wichtig ist natürlich, ist gleiche Freiheit für alle. Das heißt, Diskriminierungsschutz oder Freiheit von Diskriminierung ist auch ein wichtiges Thema.
Also du sprichst einen Fall an, den ihr auf eurer Homepage auch schildert, wo es um Equal Pay geht zum Beispiel. Da war mir jetzt die Verbindung zum Freiheitsrecht irgendwie nicht so richtig klar, aber das kannst du mit Sicherheit erläutern.
Ja, also die Verbindung zu den Freiheitsrechten ist klar. Du kannst überall arbeiten und hast dann eben das Recht, auch entsprechend für bezahlt zu werden. Und das kann aber irgendwie nicht sein, dass die Hälfte der Bevölkerung da schlechtere Bedingungen hat als die anderen. Und das ist einfach ein Fairness-Problem. Und das ist dann ehrlich, also wenn man das als marktliberale Freiheit vielleicht versteht, dann funktioniert der Markt nicht. Wenn da ein paar Leute nicht faire Verhandlungsbedingungen haben, sondern einfach mit schlechteren Gehältern sich zufriedengeben müssen. Dass wir jetzt, wenn man das jetzt wirklich auf das Freiheitsrecht unterbrechen will, aber Freiheitsrechte ist für uns tatsächlich sozusagen eine Kurzfassung für Grund- und Menschenrechte in ihrer Breite. Das wäre vielleicht jetzt so als Endgeronahm ein bisschen lang geworden.
Und das Interessante, das Spannende ist ja, ihr seid jetzt nicht einfach nur für Leute da, die jetzt einen Anwalt brauchen, weil sie sich in ihren Grundrechten eingeschränkt sehen, sondern es geht dabei darum, das für alle anderen mit durchzusetzen. Also euch ist schon daran gelegen, die Bedingungen in der Gesetzeslage in Deutschland so mitzubeinflussen, dass alle von Freiheitsrechten profitieren in gleicher Form. Und dafür nehmt ihr euch einzelne Fälle, um sozusagen ein Exempel zu statuieren? Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, das kann man so sagen. Also wir nennen das strategische Prozessführung. Jetzt hat natürlich jeder Anwalt und jede Anwältin eine Prozessstrategie. Also die überlegen sich natürlich, wie man da am schlausten vorgeht und wie man jetzt am besten argumentiert und ob man das jetzt noch bringt oder nicht oder so. Strategische Prozessführung heißt demgegenüber, dass wir unsere Fälle noch stärker selektieren, als man das als Anwält oder Anwältin vielleicht machen würde. Da überlegt man sich ja auch, nehme ich den Fall jetzt oder nicht. Aber bei uns sind natürlich auch die Ressourcen begrenzt. Das heißt, wir überlegen sehr genau, welchen von den vielen möglichen Fällen wollen wir jetzt nehmen. Unser Kriterium dabei ist eben zu sagen, da können wir jetzt mal so eine wirklich große, offene Frage klären. Oder da ist so ein strukturelles, gesellschaftliches Problem dahinter. Und der Fall steht jetzt so exemplarisch für dieses Problem. Und da können sich dann eben auch später weitere Klagen drauf stützen. Und manchmal machen wir das eben, dass wir Gegengesetze direkt vorgehen. Also dass wir direkt nach Karlsruhe gehen. Das ist unter bestimmten Bedingungen möglich. Meistens muss man da eigentlich durch die unteren Instanzen erst mal durch. Aber wir unterstützen eben auch ausgesuchte Fälle vor den einfachen Gerichten. Und das machen wir zum Beispiel jetzt vor einem Strafgericht, aber auch vor einem Arbeitsgericht. Also da sind wir, wenn das ein Fall ist, der quasi passt. Und du hast ja jetzt das Thema Entgeltgleichheit gerade angesprochen. Das ist zum Beispiel ein Fall, der jetzt vom Landesarbeitsgericht hier in Berlin-Brandenburg anhängig ist. Da unterstützen wir zum Beispiel eine Journalistin, die das ZDF verklagt, weil sie eben ungleich bezahlt wird. Sie hat bei ihren männlichen Kollegen da mehr verdienen als sie. Da ist sie kein Einzelfall. Und da gibt es aber viel zu wenig Klagen. Und deswegen ist das eine Klage, die wir unterstützen, weil wir da der Meinung sind, es ist wichtig, jetzt mal auch zu zeigen, dass geht und das kann man durchsetzen. Und das ist nicht nur irgendwie unfair oder ist halt so, sondern das ist auch rechtswidrig. Also da gibt es einen Rechtsanspruch auf gleiche Bezahlung. Und da wollen wir eben auch andere ermutigen, ebenso dagegen vorzugehen.
Das heißt, es ist nicht nur strategische Prozessführung angesagt oder Prozessplanung und auch Fallplanung, sondern euch geht es ja schon auch ein bisschen darum, dass die Leute davon erfahren. Das ist ja eigentlich auch mit wichtig bei euch, oder? Wie wählt ihr denn dann so Fälle aus, dass das auch klar ist, dass die Menschen auch verstehen, worum es da eigentlich genau geht?
Ja, das ist ein wichtiger Aspekt in der Tat unserer Arbeit, weil Fälle, die hinter verschlossenen Türen behandelt werden und wo dann hinterher nur die Juristen und Juristinnen wissen, was bei rausgekommen ist, da hat man jetzt, glaube ich, das Potenzial von der strategischen Prozessführung noch nicht ganz ausgenutzt. Es geht uns schon auch darum, an so einem Fall auch zu zeigen, was passiert da eigentlich gerade, warum kann das vielleicht auch dich betreffen, warum ist das irgendwie gesellschaftlich wichtig? Und dabei auch so ein bisschen uns die Verfassung zurückzuholen, vielleicht zu sagen, die Verfassung ist das, was wir daraus machen, und wir müssen die auch einfordern und ausnutzen. Und das ist eben unser rechtliches Mittel, staatliches Handeln zu kontrollieren. Wir haben eben eine Regierung, die darf nicht alles, sondern die darf nur das, was die Verfassung erlaubt. Und wenn wir das nicht einfordern, dann bröckelt das vielleicht auch so ein bisschen. Und wenn wir so ein bisschen nach Osteuropa gucken, dann kann einem Angst und Bange werden, wenn die Verfassung nicht mehr sozusagen die Grenze halten kann, dessen, was eine Regierung so machen darf. Also das ist uns schon wichtig, aber wir suchen eben die Fälle einmal thematisch aus, aber wir suchen dann auch nach Klägern und Klägerinnen, die praktisch den Fall auch plastisch machen können für Leute, die sich jetzt mit den Rechtsfragen nicht so auskennen, sondern die dann verstehen, was ist das Problem dahinter, was sind vielleicht auch die Gefahren, die da zusammenhängen. Und das müssen natürlich Leute sein, die auch dann so einen Fall durchstehen, die länger dabei bleiben können. Und wir machen dabei eben auch Öffentlichkeitsarbeit und versuchen, das verständlich zu kommunizieren, was wir da machen.
Ja, Nora hat ja gerade das Schlagwort Regierung ins Spiel gemacht. Die Regierung darf natürlich nur im Rahmen ihres verfassungsmäßigen Spielraums arbeiten. Aber das gilt genauso für den Gesetzgeber. Und das ist, denke ich, ein Stichwort, das ganz wichtig ist. Gerade so in Zeiten einer großen Koalition, wenn also im Bundestag eine doch überwältigende Mehrheit zustande gekommen ist, für die die Regierung trägt, dann hat man doch häufig das Gefühl, dass Freiheitsrechte einfach nicht mehr den Stellenwert bekommen im Gesetzgebungsverfahren, der ihnen eigentlich zukommen müsste. Das heißt also, Freiheitsrechte kommen einfach sehr schnell unter die Räder im Bundestag, gerade wenn eine große Koalition am Roder ist, die einfach mit einer sehr komfortablen Mehrheit regieren kann. Und insofern ist unsere Hoffnung, dass unsere Klagen auch nicht nur quasi Erfolg haben, dass wir also nicht nur verfassungswidrige Gesetze kippen können, sondern wir wollen mittelfristig auch wieder auf den Gesetzgeber einwirken und einfach dafür sorgen, hoffentlich, dass in den Parlamenten Freiheitsrechte wieder einen größeren Stellenwert einnehmen. Also wir verstehen uns überhaupt nicht als antidemokratisch, ganz im Gegenteil. Auch wenn wir natürlich häufig die Arbeit des Gesetzgebers angreifen müssen, dann machen wir das nicht, weil wir was gegen den Gesetzgeber haben, sondern wir haben was dagegen, wenn der Gesetzgeber seine Spielräume überschreitet. Wir würden uns nichts mehr wünschen, als dass das Argument, hey, das ist aber verfassungswidrig, im Bundestag wieder ein No-Go wäre. Ja, das ist doch genau das Problem, dass im Bundestag häufig gesagt wird, ja, verfassungswidrig, ich mohe mal gucken, mal schauen, was Karlsruhe sagt. Stattdessen wäre es doch eigentlich Aufgabe der Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier, dass sie die Freiheitsrechte und andere wichtige Interessen in Abwägung bringen.
Da habe ich mal einen Einwurf ganz kurz. Und zwar gibt es, wenn man so Twitter durchscrollt zu genau dieser Frage, was dürfen Parlamentarier sich eigentlich leisten, wenn es darum geht, ist das, was sie da verabschieden, potenziell verfassungswidrig. Da gibt es so viele Leute, die sagen, das darf nicht, da braucht man Sanktionsmittel. Direkt gegen die Parlamentarier, findest du das eine gute Idee?
Nein, das finde ich keine gute Idee. Ich finde, dass die Freiheit und die Unabhängigkeit des Bundestagsmandats zum Beispiel oder auch der Landtagsmandate finde ich extrem wichtig. Ich halte deswegen nichts davon, dass man Abgeordnete dafür bestraft, wenn sie ein Gesetz erlassen, das sich hinterher als verfassungswidrig erweist. Ich würde mir erwünschen, dass sich die politische Kultur ein wenig ändert. Ich würde mir quasi eine politische Sanktionierung wünschen. Nicht, dass die Menschen irgendwie die Diäten gekürzt bekommen oder ein Bußgeld zahlen müssen, sondern ich würde mir wünschen, dass die Bürgerinnen und Bürger einfach systematisch Parlamentarier abstrafen, die verfassungswidrige Gesetze durchboxen.
Sorry, aber das ist genau das, was wir mit unserer Öffentlichkeitsarbeit versuchen zu stärken, also dieses Bewusstsein, was die Verfassung eigentlich für eine Funktion hat und was sie leisten kann und wie ich sie auch nutzen kann als Bürger oder Bürgerin. Und da wieder so eine Verfassungskultur zu stärken, dass das im öffentlichen Diskurs wieder eine größere Rolle spielt und dass die Leute sich damit sicherer fühlen und dass sie auch wissen, wie sie damit argumentieren können. Also das ist irgendwie so eine Legal Literacy, also so eine Lesefähigkeit der Verfassung zu schaffen.
Also vielleicht, um da mal ein Schlagwort ins Spiel zu bringen, wir bezeichnen uns als GFF immer sehr gerne quasi als die Rechtsschutzversicherung des Grundgesetzes. Das Grundgesetz kann ja nicht selber für sich klagen, aber wir wollen im Grunde sicherstellen, dass wenn jemand dem Grundgesetz auf die Füße tritt, dass dann dagegen auch geklagt werden kann.
Jetzt hast du gerade die Literacy angesprochen. Also sozusagen, ja, also...
Lese- und Schreibfähigkeit.
Wir haben noch ein anderes Wort dafür. Wir müssen die Menschen mehr zum Verständnis des Grundgesetzes alphabetisieren gewissermaßen. Aber das ist ja, bleibt ja auch hochkomplex. Selbst wenn man sich jetzt mal zutraut, einen Gesetzestext durchzulesen oder das Grundgesetz durchzulesen, ist ja natürlich auch Schulinhalt alles. Aber es ist auch schwer zu wissen, wann werden denn eigentlich meine Freiheitsrechte eingeschränkt? Also das heißt, wie findet ihr denn tatsächlich auch die Kläger? Kommen die zu euch, weil die merken, da kann irgendwas nicht stimmen? Oder sucht ihr strategisch?
Ja, das machen wir beides. Also wir kriegen oft Anfragen und drücken die dann sehr genau und gucken, ist das inhaltlich was für uns? Ist das von der Wirkung her was für uns? Ist das sozusagen ein Präzedenzfall? Ein möglicher, um den es hier geht? Aber auch ist der Fall prozessual noch zu gewinnen? Manchmal sind ja auch schon Sachen schiefgegangen, die sich dann irgendwann nicht mehr retten lassen. Also das gibt durchaus Anfragen, die zu uns kommen und die wir dann im Zweifel auch dann annehmen. Also das haben wir auch schon mehrfach getan. Aber was wir eben auch machen, ist, dass wir uns die Fälle suchen und sagen, hier passiert was, da müssen wir ran. Und dann, wir machen eigentlich, bearbeiten unsere Fälle eigentlich immer mit einer Partnerorganisation. Wir haben z.B. jetzt viel mit Reporter ohne Grenzen gearbeitet. Oder mit Amnesty International, mit Netzpolitik haben wir auch zusammen einen Fall. Also da haben wir verschiedene Partner, die in einem Bereich praktisch tätig sind. Und wir liefern dann die rechtliche Expertise. Weil das ist nämlich auch unsere Wahrnehmung. Klar, man hat so ein Gefühl, das kann doch nicht sein. Aber wie das jetzt genau juristisch ist, da braucht man dann doch die Profis, sag ich mal. Also die sich mit dem Verfassungsrecht auskennen und die auch das Know-how haben, so ein Verfahren zu führen und auch eine Verfassungsbeschwerde zu schreiben, wo man jetzt nicht vermeidbare Fehler macht, sag ich mal. Da scheitern ja schon sehr viele Fälle in Karlsruhe schon an den formalen Anforderungen. Und das heißt, da versuchen wir eben die Expertise beizusteuern, jetzt nicht zu sagen, wir doppeln jetzt die Arbeit, wir sind jetzt noch ein Investi und noch ein Reporter und noch eine Netzpolitik, sondern nein, wir sind die GFF. Wir liefern die juristische Expertise und wir geben diesen Gruppen noch ein weiteres Mittel in die Hand, nämlich das Recht.
Ihr sagt auch, ihr konzentriert euch hauptsächlich auf sozusagen eine Gefahr, das ist jetzt mein Wort, die sozusagen vom deutschen Staat kommt. Jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, die meisten Menschen sehen den Staat gar nicht mehr sozusagen als Quelle von irgendwelchen Gefahren, sondern eher so als Schutz, nämlich vor einer Gefahr, die von globalen Unternehmen irgendwie ausgeht. Habt ihr die nur einfach nicht auf dem Schirm? Ist das sozusagen einfach nicht euer Thema? Oder seht ihr tatsächlich, die größere Gefahr für die Freiheitsrechte eher vom deutschen Staat ausgeht?
Ich denke, da sollte man sich gar nicht auf dieses Ping-Pong-Spiel anlassen. Ist der Staat schlimmer oder sind die Privaten schlimmer? Man muss sich zum Beispiel klarmachen, Daten, die irgendein privates Unternehmen erhoben hat, gesammelt hat, auf die kann der Staat praktisch immer zugreifen. Also Google, obwohl es ein amerikanisches Unternehmen ist, arbeitet ganz intensiv auch mit deutschen Ermittlungsbehörden zusammen. Dieser Gegensatz, der ja auch von der Politik häufig aufgemacht wird, der ist ehrlich gesagt eher Augenwischerei. Wir konzentrieren uns vor allem deswegen auch auf staatliche Eingriffe, jedenfalls im Bereich Datenschutz und Datensicherheit, weil wir da in der Absprache haben auch mit Max Schrems, Datenschutzaktivist aus Österreich, hat ja jetzt auch gerade eine NGO gegründet, die auch schon seit Jahren in der Planung war, die NEUB, None of Your Business, der sich eben konzentriert auf Datenschutzverstöße durch Privatunternehmen und Max und wir haben einfach schon seit Jahren quasi so die Absprache, hey, du machst die Privaten im Bereich Datenschutz und die GFF kümmert sich um staatliche Verletzungen von der Privatsphäre. Aber das gilt nur so für den Bereich Datenschutz. Also im Bereich Equal Pay zum Beispiel gehen wir ja auch gegen einen privaten Akteur, das ZDF, vor im Bereich Equal Pay. Also diese Beschränkung auf staatliche Akteure gilt streng nur im Bereich Datenschutz, weil wir da einfach die Aufgaben mit Max Schrems aufgeteilt haben.
Wo seht ihr denn die Freiheitsrechte jetzt von welcher Seite am meisten bedroht? Ihr habt ja verschiedene Fälle. Was ist denn das, wo ihr sagt, okay, da müssen wir massiv gegen vorgehen?
Ja, also da würde ich sagen, dass der Datenschutz einfach ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Also die Überwachungskompetenzen und der polizeilichen Kompetenzen, Sicherheitsdienst und so weiter, das ist im Moment, passiert da einfach wahnsinnig viel. Und ich glaube, da braucht es schon eine große fachliche Expertise, um technisch schon zu verstehen, was da eigentlich genau passiert. Und was da eigentlich so alles noch möglicherweise mit angesprochen ist, das wird, glaube ich, in den Medien, muss das so verkürzt werden, dass das nicht vielleicht alle so ganz einschätzen können. Und ich habe es vorhin schon gesagt, da ist so ein bisschen die Sensibilität ein bisschen runtergegangen. Also das ist, glaube ich, schon ein Thema, das wird uns erhalten bleiben. Das sehen wir auch, dass der Gesetzgeber da einfach sehr aktiv ist.
Wie vermittelt man diese Sensibilität? Tatsächlich ist das auch ein Problem, dass ich beispielsweise in anderen Talksendungen auch immer wieder mal bemerkt habe, dass es schwer zu sagen ist, wobei Datenschutz eigentlich das Problem bei mir anfängt. Also wie vermittelt man sozusagen die Wichtigkeit von Datenschutz?
Da haben wir zum Beispiel mit Reporter ohne Grenzen zusammengearbeitet und mit Amnesty und haben uns da Kläger und Klägerinnen gesucht, die als investigative Journalisten oder Journalistinnen arbeiten, die mit Whistleblowern arbeiten und für die einfach Datensicherheit und Quellenschutz wahnsinnig wichtig ist. Das sind Berufsgeheimnisträger. Und wenn wir da quasi eine Situation schaffen, wo Quellen fürchten müssen, offengelegt zu werden, wo möglicherweise die als Menschenrechtsverteidiger jetzt in Staaten aktiv sind, wo sie wirklich Angst haben müssen um ihr Leben, da lässt es sich glaube ich vermitteln, dass, naja, ich habe nichts zu verbergen, einfach nicht für alle gilt. Und das ist so eine Art, wie wir versuchen, dieses Datenschutzproblem zu erzählen und zu sagen, ja, kann schon sein, dass dir das nicht wichtig ist, aber guck dir mal die Situation an, das geht nicht. Und da müssen wir einfach sehen, dass der Staat Mechanismen schafft, die entsprechenden Schutz liefern, die nicht zu weit gehen, die wirklich auch nur in Fällen, wo es nötig ist, diese Überwachung erlauben und so. Und das kann doch nicht sein, dass das einfach so komplett ausgeweitet wird, da sind wirklich Gefahren dahinter. Und deswegen versuchen wir dann so eine Fälle so zu erzählen anhand von Personen, die wir als Beispiel nehmen, die das vielleicht ein bisschen anschaulich machen können.
Das ist das eine große Feld, was Nora gerade geschildert hat. Und mir persönlich liegt auch sehr am Herzen das Feld der Pressefreiheit. Denn ich denke, dass die Presse einfach in einer Demokratie eine unglaublich wichtige Funktion hat, um das Handeln des Staates und der Politiker und Politikerinnen kritisch zu begleiten, das zu analysieren, zu erklären, zu hinterfragen. Demokratie funktioniert einfach nicht ohne eine freie Presse. Und das bedeutet, die muss recherchieren können, die muss ihre Quellen schützen können. Journalistinnen und Journalisten müssen selber sicher sein können, dass sie recherchieren können, ohne dass das für sie persönlich Nachteile hat. Und da muss man halt einfach sagen, sehe ich den Freiheitsraum zurzeit sehr begrenzt. Also die Presse hat zum einen natürlich ökonomische Probleme. Das hat viel zu tun mit der Entwicklung des Internet, weil es eben so viele gratis Angebote gibt. Das ist ein anderes Thema, das ist jetzt eher nicht unser Thema, aber das führt eh dazu, dass Journalismus enorm unter Strom steht zurzeit. Und das zweite Problem ist eben, dass diese Überwachungstechnologien, die es gibt, freien Journalismus immer weiter erschweren. Und deswegen haben wir uns so sehr die Pressefreiheit auf die Fahnen geschrieben, einfach als eine Funktionsbedingung einer freiheitlichen Demokratie. Wenn Journalistinnen und Journalisten ihren Job nicht mehr machen können, wenn Whistleblower eben verstummen, weil sie Angst haben erwischt zu werden, dann ist aus meiner Sicht die Demokratie als solche bedroht. Es braucht einfach Menschen, die sehr laut vernehmlich die Trillerpfeife blasen, um im Bild zu bleiben, wenn irgendwas schief läuft. Und auch in einem Staat, der im Großen und Ganzen, denke ich, sehr gut funktioniert, gerade im internationalen Vergleich wie in Deutschland, gibt es immer wieder Dinge, die auf gut Deutsch zum Himmel schreien. Und dann ist es wichtig, dass darüber auch diskutiert werden kann und berichtet werden kann.
Die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte findet ihr im Internet unter freiheitsrechte.org. Und da kann man auch eine Auswahl der ganzen Fälle sehen, die von der GFF momentan behandelt werden. Und da geht es natürlich auch um die Strategie, also im Grunde das, worüber wir jetzt hier gerade gesprochen haben, lässt sich da nachlesen. Spenden kann man übrigens auch. Ich tippe mal, dass sozusagen die großen Spender jetzt nicht auf den Spende-Button auf dem Internet klicken, sondern dass ihr die über andere Kanäle anspricht. Aber wie man sich beteiligen kann, darüber sprechen wir später noch. Mit dem Spenden-Button geht das auf jeden Fall auch unter freiheitsrechte.org. Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, verabschiedet sich Nora Marquardt an dieser Stelle? Genau. Und wir reden gleich noch weiter mit Ulf Burmeier, möglicherweise über das Anti-Whistleblower-Gesetz, das hier schon angesprochen wurde, zu dem mir ein Satz von Daniel Ellsberg eingefallen ist. Der Mann hinter den Pentagon-Papers jetzt also verfilmt in die Verlegerin, der nämlich sagte, you can't have a democracy without unauthorized disclosures. Also man kann keine Demokratie haben, ohne unerlaubtes Weiterzählen von gewissen Dingen. Tschüss Nora, vielen Dank. Ciao. Chaosradio Nr. 246, wir haben es kurz nach 11. Wir reden über Freiheitsrechte in diesen zwei Stunden in dieser Ausgabe. Zu Gast schon die gesamte Zeit ist Ulf Buermeyer. Ihr kennt ihn von der Lage der Nationen im Podcast. Er ist aber Gründer und Vorsitzender der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte ebenfalls. Außerdem Richter am Landgericht Berlin und Sachverständiger im Innenausschuss des Bundestags zur Neustrukturierung des Bundeskriminalamtsgesetz. Insofern also auch schwer vertraut mit Dingen, die da möglicherweise jetzt noch auf uns zukommen in Berlin. Eben haben wir noch gehört, Nora Markert, Professorin in Hamburg für Öffentliches Recht, auch sie bei der GFF. Und die GFF beschäftigt uns natürlich noch weiter und einige ihrer Fälle. Etwas Spektakuläres, wo sozusagen das Verständnis, was Freiheit eigentlich bedeutet, vor allen Dingen Freiheit im Datenschutz bedeutet, ist immer genau diese Geschichte, die wir gerade schon angesprochen haben, mit Whistleblowern. Wir haben vor kurzem jetzt einen Film in den Kinos gehabt, die Verlegerin, da geht es um die Pentagon Papers, in denen erstmals sozusagen dargestellt wurde, wie schlimm die Amerikaner in den 60er Jahren in Vietnam dastanden, wie schlecht die Situation sozusagen aus Sicht der Amerikaner im Krieg war und wie lange das vereimlicht wurde, dass sozusagen Menschen offensichtlich als Soldaten in diesen Krieg geschickt wurde, der von der eigenen Regierung schon nicht mehr als gewinnbar eingeschätzt war. Und das ist ein Leak gewesen von Daniel Ellsberg. Und darum geht es in diesem Film. Und er hat eben auch gesagt, diesen Satz, den ich beeindruckend finde, in einem Vice-Interview war das, You can't have a democracy without unauthorized disclosures. Also man kann keine Demokratie haben, ohne nicht ab und zu mal auch ein kleines Geheimnis zu verraten. Uff, das ist ja dann auch nicht mehr recht an der Stelle, wenn jemand ein Geheimnis tatsächlich verrät oder doch?
Ja, das ist schon richtig, was du sagst. In den meisten Fällen ist es so, dass die Whistleblower schon gegen irgendein Gesetz verstoßen. Wenn sie Beamte sind, ist es häufig ein Verrat von Dienstgeheimnissen. Oder wenn es Mitarbeiter in einer Firma sind, kann es auch der Verrat von Geschäftsgeheimnissen sein. Also da gibt es schon viele Gesetze, gegen die man verstoßen kann als Whistleblower. Deswegen wäre es so wichtig, dass man einen Rechtsrahmen schafft, der unter bestimmten Bedingungen Whistleblowing legal macht. Das wäre natürlich der Idealfall, wenn man sich also gar nicht mehr strafbar machen würde. Wenigstens aber, solange wir so weit nicht gekommen sind, muss es möglich sein, dass Whistleblowing an die Presse straffrei bleibt. Und wenn wir da keine Straffreiheit direkt schaffen können, dann ist die zweitbeste Lösung, dass die Whistleblower jedenfalls darauf vertrauen können, dass man sie nicht erwischen wird. Und das ist einer der vielen, vielen Gründe, warum Internet-Massenüberwachung oder warum zum Beispiel auch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung so gefährlich ist, weil man damit eben unter anderem auch die Kommunikationsbeziehung von Journalistinnen und Journalisten aufdecken kann.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, also was wiegt da mehr? Das Geheimnis, weil es beispielsweise um Staatssicherheit geht oder gerade bei den Pentagon Papers um die Lage der Nationen natürlich auch. Oder das Interesse der Öffentlichkeit an den Dingen, die da ans Licht gebracht werden. Wer darf das denn eigentlich abwägen? Also wenn jemand mit solchen entsprechenden Geheimnissen zu euch kommen würde, dürftet ihr den hören oder dürftet ihr mit diesen Informationen irgendetwas anstellen?
Also ich würde ehrlich gesagt zunächst mal sagen, zur GFF sollte man mit solchen Staatsgeheimnissen nicht kommen, sondern das ist genau der Punkt, deswegen habe ich das eben auch gleich ins Spiel gebracht. Ich finde, solche Leaks sollten immer an Journalistinnen und Journalisten gehen. Und zwar einfach deswegen, weil die dafür ausgebildet sind, einzuschätzen, ob diese Informationen tatsächlich echt sind zunächst mal. Das ist ja eine ganz wichtige Frage. Es kann ja auch sein, dass es einfach Fake News sind. Das ist das eine. Und zum anderen, weil die natürlich auch dazu ausgebildet sind, abzuwägen, welches Interesse denn jetzt im konkreten Einsfall überwiegt. Ob sie diese Informationen verwerten, ob sie sie direkt veröffentlichen, ob sie quasi die PDF-Datei ins Netz stellen oder ob sie nur bestimmte Informationen daraus verwenden, um dann weiter zu recherchieren zum Beispiel. Und deswegen denke ich, man muss durchaus jetzt keine Radikal-Lösung dergestalt schaffen, dass man sagt, man schafft einfach alle Dienstgeheimnisse ab. Es gibt ja auch Dienstgeheimnisse, die durchaus einen bestimmten Sinn machen. Du hast gerade schon zum Beispiel so Fälle der nationalen Sicherheit oder der Verteidigung angeführt. Es ist ja völlig klar, dass man jetzt irgendwie die Geheimnisse der Bundeswehr in bestimmten Situationen schützen muss. Aber man muss sie aus meiner Sicht eben nicht schützen vor Leaks an die Presse, denn da vertraue ich darauf, dass Journalistinnen und Journalisten dann verantwortungsbewusst damit umgehen und keine Hierarchiereaktionen starten. Ich finde wichtig bei dieser Abwägung den Gedanken, den du eben schon zitiert hast von Daniel Ellsberg, dass es eben keine Demokratie gibt ohne Leaks. Und dann möchte ich noch ein bisschen präzisieren. Es muss ja durchaus nicht so sein, dass alle Informationen irgendwann geleakt werden. Ich finde das Wesentliche ist, dass alle Menschen, die mit Geheimnissen arbeiten, wissen, es könnte sein, dass sie geleakt werden. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht eine zentrale Bedingung dafür, dass die Menschen sich in Behörden auch noch ans Recht halten. Wenn ich in einer Behörde arbeite und quasi willkürlich Informationen als geheim deklarieren kann und wenn ich dann darauf vertrauen kann, dass es wirklich niemand mehr prüfen kann, dass es niemals seinen Weg in die Presse findet, dann bin ich ja nicht mehr gehindert alle möglichen, sagen wir mal, jedenfalls rechtlich fragwürdigen Dinge zu tun, weil ja einfach niemand mehr drauf guckt. Wenn ich aber damit rechnen muss, dass vielleicht jedenfalls jedes tausendste Geheimnis tatsächlich irgendwann in der BILD-Zeitung steht, dann werde ich möglicherweise mir zweimal überlegen, ob ich bei meiner Arbeit unter dem Schutz von Geheimnissen das Recht breche. Also deswegen würde ich ganz im Gegenteil sagen, der Rechtsstaat verlangt, dass es jedenfalls ein Risiko eines liegt. Es muss nicht alles geleakt werden, aber jeder, der mit geheimen Unterlagen arbeitet, der muss im Geiste davon ausgehen, es könnte ein Lieg geben, um tatsächlich sich selbst noch ans Recht zu halten.
Das heißt, der umgekehrte Satz von Erzberg stimmt ja eigentlich dann auch. Es kann keine Demokratie ohne Geheimnisse geben. Kann man den auch so stehen lassen?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich denke, dass es schon einfach viele Bereiche gibt, in denen die Verwaltung mit Daten arbeitet, die nicht so ohne weiteres an die Öffentlichkeit kommen sollten. Zum Beispiel, weil es die Öffentlichkeit einfach verunsichern könnte und dann zu Panikreaktionen führen könnte. Insofern glaube ich, muss man schon in manchen Situationen sich sehr genau überlegen, was man veröffentlicht. Ich bin also insofern kein radikaler Gegner, jedes Verwaltungsgeheimnisses. Ich sehe da schon, dass es bestimmte Grenzen geben muss. Ich denke nur, dass wir in einer Kultur leben, wo die Verwaltung es mit den Geheimnissen traditionell sehr übertreibt. Aber da leben wir gerade in einer Zeit, wo ein langsamer, ganz gemächlicher Kulturwandel einsetzt. Stichwort Informationsfreiheitsgesetze, also immer mehr Bürgerinnen und Bürger stellen Fragen an die Verwaltung, möchten einfach wissen, mit was die Verwaltung so arbeitet. Und wir erleben da auch als GFF ja mehr ein Programm, das wir Transparenzklagen nennen, wo wir also Menschen unterstützen, deren IFG-Anträge abgelehnt worden sind, wo Behörden also Unterlagen nicht rausrücken wollten. Als GFF erleben wir also schon noch erhebliche Widerstände in den Behörden, das muss man deutlich sagen. Also nicht alle Beamtinnen und Beamten finden das so richtig gut, sich in die Karten schauen zu lassen. Viele haben noch so diesen alten preußischen Gedanken im Kopf, das sind meine Akten. Und ich vertraue aber darauf, dass sich da einfach ein Kulturwandel einstellen wird, dahin zu sagen, das sind nicht die Akten der Behörde, sondern das sind die Akten der Menschen in Deutschland, denn die haben schließlich die Behörde bezahlt mit ihren Steuern.
Lassen wir uns noch mal kurz bei den Wisseblowern bleiben. Was haben wir denn für eine rechtliche Lage momentan? Also wenn ich jetzt im Besitz von sensiblen Informationen bin, die irgendwelche Betrügereien oder dunkle Machenschaften von Seiten des Gesetzgebers beinhalten, jetzt sagst du, okay, geh zum Journalisten, die können das durchchecken, aber was ist denn dann der rechtliche Rahmen am Ende? Also bin ich in irgendeiner Form geschützt, wenn da öffentliches Interesse besteht? Wie sieht es aus?
Also Journalistinnen und Journalisten haben grundsätzlich ein Zeugnis Verweigerungsrecht. Das heißt also, sie müssen zunächst mal keine Auskunft geben über den Namen und die oder sonst die Identität ihrer Informantinnen und Informanten. Da gibt es einen grundsätzlichen Schutz. Der hat zwar hier und da auch Lücken, das muss man ehrlich sagen, aber jedenfalls grundsätzlich mal gibt es einen Schutz, der ist nicht 150% perfekt, weil in manchen Situationen quasi auch eine Abwägung stattfinden muss. Da ist es also kein absoluter Schutz, sondern da wird abgewogen zwischen dem quasi dem Quellenschutz und anderen Interessen. Aber im Großen und Ganzen...
Wer übernimmt denn solche Abwägungen eigentlich?
Ja, es gibt zum Beispiel so Abwägungsklauseln im BKA-Gesetz. Es gibt ja auch nach dem BKA-Gesetz eine ganze Reihe heimlicher Überwachungsmaßnahmen und normalerweise dürfen Daten von Journalistinnen und Journalisten nicht verwandt werden, die dabei so quasi im Filter hängen bleiben, aber es gibt eben Ausnahmefälle, wo das doch geht. Insofern, das geht jetzt sehr ins Detail, deswegen will ich das nicht zu lange ausführen. Ich wollte nur sagen, die Grundregel ist aber schon, dass es sowas gibt wie einen Quellenschutz, also grundsätzlich müssen Menschen, die bei der Presse arbeiten, ihre Quellen nicht offenlegen. Es gibt ein paar Lücken, aber im Grundsatz zählt es schon und man muss sich einfach nur überlegen, mit welchen Kommunikationsmitteln wende ich mich an die Presse und man muss leider sagen, in den Zeiten, wo eben extrem viel elektronische Kommunikation gespeichert wird, jedenfalls quasi die Umstände der Kommunikation, die sogenannten Metadaten, also wer hat mit wem kommuniziert, da ist immer noch das sicherste, einfach einen Brief zu schicken. So traurig das ist. Wenn man heikle Informationen hat, die per E-Mail zu schicken, ist nicht so ganz ungefährlich. Das kann man auch machen, wenn man sehr genau weiß, was man tut. Manche Medien haben ja sogenannte Secure Drop Systeme, da geht das relativ gut, aber wenn man jetzt sagt, ich bin jetzt eher nicht so der Techie, dann sollte man heikle Informationen schlicht per Brief an die Redaktion schicken. Dann hat man die allerbesten Karten, dass man keine Spuren hinterlässt.
Ich darf aber auch eine CD brennen, das geht dann schon.
Wir sind eben wirklich durch eine Vielzahl von Überwachungsgesetzen und durch unglaublich viele Datenspeicherungen in allen Ecken und Enden in einer Situation, wo es sehr gefährlich ist, mit digitalen Mitteln Informationen an die Presse zu übermitteln. Es sei denn, man weiß sehr genau, was man tut. Es gibt Möglichkeiten, dem zu entgehen. Also eine naheliegende ist zum Beispiel, wenn man die Handynummer hat einer Journalistin, Signal ist relativ sicher als Messenger, weil die eben keine Metadaten speichern. Die könnten das theoretisch, sie schwören aber, dass sie das nicht tun. Und Menschen, denen ich vertraue, sagen, man kann denen vertrauen. Also Signal ist, denke ich, zurzeit vielleicht der beste Kompromiss zwischen User-Freundlichkeit und Sicherheit, um Daten an die Presse zu bringen. Aber dann muss man halt die Handynummer kennen, des Menschen, den man da anfunkten will.
Und der muss dann auch Signal haben. Jetzt sagt er, Danimo ist natürlich auch zu Gast hier. Hab ich gar nicht mehr vorgestellt. Aber jetzt muss er reinspringen.
Ja, das mit dem Papier wollte ich noch mal gerade ein bisschen.
Das schmeckt dem Chaos Computer Club gar nicht mehr.
Ja, wir erinnern uns, es gab letztens einen Fall, wo jemand genau daran, dass er das über einen Kopierer gejagt hat, die Dokumente. Und das gibt es auch bei Druckern, die hinterlassen mittlerweile auch eindeutige Signaturen auf dem Papier, die nicht wirklich sichtbar sind, es sei denn, man weiß genau, wo man hingucken muss. Darüber lässt sich dann gegebenenfalls auch die Geräte nochmal identifizieren. Darüber lässt sich dann meistens gerade, wenn man das auf einem Firmenrechner macht, identifizieren, wer das gedruckt hat, oder auf einem Behördendrucker. Ist also auch nicht so einfach. Also tatsächlich vielleicht erst mal Tufühlung mit einem Journalisten aufnehmen.
Und dann sollen die sagen, wie die Informationen übermittelt werden.
Genau.
Bevor man einfach was schickt. Gibt es denn spektakuläre Blowerfälle, von denen ich jetzt in Deutschland nichts weiß? Ich denke immer nur an Edward Snowden und dann natürlich geht der Gedanke an die Pentagon-Papers oder Panama-Papers, hier Paradise-Papers. Da waren ja mehrere P-Papers, die die letzten beiden hatten, mit Steueroasen zu tun. Gibt es Fälle, wo man sagen könnte, dass es ja da hat man doch gesehen, wie das funktioniert?
Also rund um den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss zum Beispiel gab es ja eine ganze Reihe von auch prominenten Leaks, wo einfach Informationen durchgestochen wurden. Teilweise wurde dann ja auch quasi von Seiten der Behörden sehr deutlich das kritisiert und so getan, als wenn quasi der Bundestag systematisch undicht sei. Und das wurde dann wiederum als Argument verwendet, dass man dem Bundestag möglichst wenig Informationen geben soll. Und interessanterweise haben dann Journalistinnen und Journalisten gesagt, naja, also nicht alles kam aus dem Parlament. Es kam auch einiges aus den Behörden, die dann ganz gezielt wiederum Propaganda gemacht haben. Also rund um den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss gab es eine ganze Menge an Whistleblowing. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel auch im privaten Bereich immer wieder solche Fälle. Wir haben ja als GFF vor kurzem oder vor anderthalb Jahren etwa eine Verfassungsbeschwerde erhoben gegen ein Strafgesetz, auf das wir vielleicht gleich noch kommen. Und da spielt ein Whistleblowing-Fall aus der Privatwirtschaft eine große Rolle, der so schön anschaulich ist. Deswegen würde ich den vielleicht mal kurz erzählen. Und zwar geht es da um die Dating-Plattform LeVou. Das ist so ein bisschen so das deutsche Tinder oder OkCupid, kannte ich auch nicht. Aber da ist es irgendwie wohl so, dass wie auf jeder Dating-Plattform es irgendwie viel mehr Männer als Frauen gibt, die die Plattform nutzen. Und das ist natürlich nicht so richtig klasse für das Geschäftsmodell, weil das für die Männer natürlich unattraktiv ist, wenn sie keine Frauen finden können. Und vor allem ist das für das Geschäftsmodell deswegen doof, weil Männer dafür bezahlen müssen auf dieser Plattform, wenn sie Frauen Nachrichten schreiben. Und wenn da wenig Frauen auf der Plattform sind, dann schreiben die Männer wenig Nachrichten und LeVou verdient wenig Geld. Deswegen haben die sich einen Trick überlegt vor einigen Jahren. Die haben einfach Frauen gefaked. Sie haben also quasi Skripten geschrieben, die dann so getan haben, als wären sie eine Frau und haben auf diese Art und Weise dazu Männer verleitet, immer mehr Nachrichten zu schreiben an diese Fakefrauen. Und das ist ein ziemlich eindeutiger Fall des Betruges oder Computerbetruges, je nachdem wie die Details jeweils sind. Und das ist durchgestochen worden an die CT, also das Computermagazin aus dem Heiseverlag. Die haben also Daten durchgestochen bekommen, ich glaube vier Gigabyte oder so, im Prinzip E-Mail-Inboxen, so Outlook-Messageboxen. Und da war quasi so der E-Mail-Verkehr der Chefetage von LeVou drin, wo man auch ganz genau sehen konnte, die wussten, was sie tun. Und das ist halt ein klassischer Fall von Whistleblowing. Der hatte einfach einen Mitarbeiter, wahrscheinlich von LeVou, der ein schlechtes Gewissen bekommen hat, hat diese Daten durchgestochen an die Presse, um das Ganze dann mal an die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen. Und das hat Heise dann natürlich auch publiziert und auch an die Staatsanwaltschaft. Der Verlag der CT rausbringt. Ja genau, der Verlag der CT rausbringt, hat das dann auch an die Staatsanwaltschaft gegeben und hat das aber auch groß berichtet. Und da sind dann tatsächlich auch Leute festgenommen worden. Also das ist schon ein Fall, der wirklich tatsächlich Folgen hatte. Und ich meine, immerhin sind da ja auch Tausende von Männern betrogen worden. Also um ihr Geld, aber auch um ihr Vertrauen. Und deswegen finde ich das ein schönes Beispiel, warum es so wichtig ist, dass man Daten durchstechen kann.
Jetzt kann man doch aber an der Stelle sehen, hat doch alles super geklappt. Dann ist die Rechtspflege doch fantastisch für Whistleblower in Deutschland.
Ganz genau. Sie war fantastisch, bis die Datenhele reichen. Na ja, sie waren natürlich nicht fantastisch. Es gibt immer noch Lücken im Whistleblower-Schutz. Wie gesagt, es ist nach wie vor noch strafbar, wenn man solche Sachen durchsticht. Das heißt, man muss immer darauf vertrauen, dass es nicht rauskommt. Das ist natürlich nicht optimal. Auch arbeitsrechtlich ist man da also überhaupt nicht abgesichert. Da könnte man immer noch gekündigt werden dafür. Insofern, die Rechtslage ist wahrlich nicht perfekt, aber sie ist 2015 auch nicht etwa verbessert, sondern noch mal deutlich verschlechtert worden, als nämlich die damalige große Koalition ein neues Strafgesetz beschlossen hat. Den Straftat bestand der Datenhelerei. Und das ist dieses Gesetz, das du schon kurz angesprochen hast. Das stellt im Prinzip unter Strafe, wenn man sich gestohlene Daten verschafft oder gestohlene Daten weitergibt, gestohlen jetzt mal untechnisch formuliert, also Daten, die irgendwie durch eine Straftat abhanden gekommen sind, wenn man die dann quasi weitergibt oder sich verschafft.
Und worum ging es da ursprünglich? Was hatten die Gesetzgeber im Visier bei diesem Paragrafen?
Ursprünglich hatten die im Visier zum Beispiel die Situation, dass Kreditkartendaten geklaut werden bei einer Zahlungsverkehrsfirma und die dann im Internet gehandelt werden. Das ist natürlich ein offensichtlicher Fall, was nicht sein sollte. Natürlich sollte man im Internet nicht irgendwie 1000 Kreditkartennummern kaufen können, um dann damit irgendwelche Betrügereien zu starten.
Und da wollte man nicht nur die Leute bestrafen können, die die Kreditkartendaten mal geklaut haben, sondern auch die, die damit dann Handel treiben.
Ganz genau, und auch noch nicht mal... Also Datenhilerei klingt so nach Handel treiben, aber schlafer macht man sich schon, wenn man die auch unentgeltlich sich einfach nur irgendwie verschafft. Das heißt also, diese Grundidee des Gesetzes war okay, das Gesetz ist aber viel zu weit formuliert. Deswegen erfasst es nicht etwa nur gestohlene Kreditkartendaten oder gestohlene Logins, was vielleicht okay wäre, sondern es erfasst einfach sämtliche Daten und darunter fallen eben auch Daten von Whistleblowern. Das ist das große Problem, weil Daten von Whistleblowern, wenn die weitergegeben werden an jemanden, dann eben auch quasi gestohlene Daten, abhandengekommene Daten sind. Wenn ich jetzt als Journalist mir diese einmal schon weitergegebenen Daten verschaffe oder sie als Journalist weitergebe an einen dritten, zum Beispiel einen CCC-Mitglied, ein Nerd, der diese Daten analysiert, dann können sich sowohl der Journalist als auch der CCC-Hacker, der also diese Daten analysieren will, strafbar machen nach der Datenhehlerei. Und das ist, wie man sich vorstellen kann, ausgesprochen gefährlich für investigativen Journalismus, weil natürlich in diesem Bereich ganz häufig mit gestohlenen Daten, mit abhandengekommenen Daten, eben mit Daten von Whistleblowern gearbeitet werden muss. Es gab ursprünglich in dem Gesetz gar keine Schutzvorschrift für Journalisten. Dann habe ich da einen Blogbeitrag geschrieben bei Netzpolitik. Daraufhin haben die das Gesetz dann auch noch ein bisschen nachgebessert, diesen Entwurf. Aber diese Schutzklausel für Journalisten ist immer noch viel zu eng. Das heißt, es gibt immer noch viele Fälle aus der Praxis, die strafbar wären. Und deswegen haben wir uns da mit Reporter ohne Grenzen zusammengetan und mit vielen anderen Menschen aus der Presse. Markus Becke dal ist zum Beispiel dabei. Oder eben auch einige Journalisten vom Heiseverlag, zum Beispiel die Leute, die damals mit den LeVu-Daten gearbeitet haben. Und die haben gesagt, das, was wir damals gemacht haben, könnten wir heute so nicht mehr tun, einfach weil es die Datenhehlerei unter Strafe stellt. Und das halten wir für gefährlich. Und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat diese Verfassungsbeschwerde inzwischen auch zugestellt. Das bedeutet, die Bundesregierung wurde aufgefordert, darauf zu antworten, auf unsere Kritik. Und das ist jetzt noch keine Vorentscheidung, aber es ist ein gutes Zeichen. Denn die allermeisten Verfassungsbeschwerden, mehr als 99 Prozent, werden gar nicht erst zugestellt, sondern werden gleich irgendwie abgelehnt. Das heißt, die Zustellung ist jedenfalls ein Zeichen, dass wir in der ganz kleinen Gruppe von Verfassungsbeschwerden sind, die Aussicht auf Erfolg haben. Aber wir haben noch nicht gewonnen. Das muss man sagen. Es bleibt abzuwarten, was passiert.
Aber das ist einer der anhängigen Fälle, die ihr mit der GFF weiter begleitet. Ich kann mir das immer so schwer vorstellen. Vielleicht ein idealisiertes Bild von den Parlamentariern, von den Menschen, die für Gesetzgebung mitverantwortlich sind. Dass die dann so eine Kritik nicht ernst nehmen. Du hast in einem Blogartikel verfasst, die sich entzündete, noch mal ein bisschen an dem Gesetz gearbeitet. Sieht man das auf der Seite des Gesetzgebers nicht, dass es da noch Probleme gibt? Oder sagt man da, na gut, jetzt ist das Ding raus, da muss der Rechtsweg beschritten werden. Die sind auch Fans von der Veränderung. Oder schlägt euch da auch Abneigung entgegen, wenn man jetzt mit dem Verfassungsgericht kommt?
Also, nee, da ist uns noch keine Abneigung entgegengeschlagen, seit wir da gegen eben nach Karlsruhe gegangen sind. Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass man im Justizministerium das jetzt nicht lustig fand, als der Brief aus Karlsruhe kam, dass es zugestellt ist, also, dass sie sich dazu bitte mal äußern sollen, weil natürlich auch die Menschen dort im Ministerium wissen, dass es ein ganz schlechtes Zeichen aus Sicht des Haares war, weil es eben so aussieht, als wenn die Verfassungsbeschwerde Erfolg haben könnte, könnte, es noch nicht entschieden könnte. Aber im Vorfeld war das schon mal ganz interessant, wir haben ja nicht erst Kritik geübt, als das Gesetz durch war, ich hab persönlich geblockt und es gab aber auch Kritik von ganz vielen anderen, also von Journalistenverbänden zum Beispiel. Und wir haben dann immer über eine Anfrage nach dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz uns mal die Akten schicken lassen zum Datenhehlerei-Paragrafen aus dem Justizministerium, um mal zu schauen, wie das Gesetz eigentlich zustande gekommen ist und wieso diese total berechtigte Kritik nicht so richtig ernst genommen wurde. Und da kann man sehen, also diese erste Kritik, der Blockbeitrag bei Netzpolitik, der ist sofort Heiko Maas, dem damaligen Minister vorgelegt worden, und der hat dann irgendwie an den Rand geschrieben, hier nachbessern. Also das ist schon passiert. Man sieht dann ja quasi die Akten aus dem Ministerium, ob die vollständig sind, wage ich nicht einzuschätzen, aber das sah man irgendwie, dieser Netzpolitik-Blockbeitrag wurde halt ausgedruckt natürlich und dann dem Minister vorgelegt und der hat dann halt gesagt, hier nachbessern, also legt mich jetzt nicht fest auf den Wortlaut, aber sinngemäß steht am Rand, bitte was tun irgendwie. Und das Problem ist bloß, dass das Gesetz dann wieder bei demselben Referenten auf dem Tisch gelandet ist, also einem bayerischen Staatsanwalt, der Abgeordnet war damals ins Ministerium und der hat dann, wie man das sieht, also richtig in den Akten hatte überhaupt keine Lust, der fand sein Gesetz schon vorher ganz großartig und den hat dann total unwillig so ein ganz kleines bisschen nachgebessert, aber hat eben das Problem überhaupt nicht ernst genommen, weil er eine Kritik an seinem Gesetzentwurf und hat deswegen eine minimale Änderung vorgenommen, die eben jetzt nicht weit genug reicht. Und das reicht. Und das ist quasi das, was wir in unserer Verfassungsbeschwerde darlegen, welche konkreten Fälle aus der journalistischen Praxis diese Schutzklausel nicht abdeckt. Und da sieht man eben sehr schön an den Akten, dass der Referent aber keinen Bock darauf hatte, das zu ändern. Der wollte einfach möglichst wenig ändern an seinem Entwurf. Und im zweiten Durchgang hat das dann auch niemand mehr so richtig geprüft. Das ist das eigentlich, Herr Schütte. Also dann kommen da diese ganzen Pressemitteilungen rein und die ganzen Mahnenbriefe von Bundestagsabgeordneten auch, die sagen, hey, mir sprechen hier die Leute von meiner Lokalzeitung ein und sagen, das ist gefährlich, was ihr da macht. Und dann wird das alles dem Referenten vorgelegt. Der Referent sagt Quatsch. Und dann geht das so raus mit so einem Standard Textbaustein. Nein, das Gesetz ist super. Also jetzt hat sich alles sehr verkürzt und ein bisschen auf den Punkt gebracht. Aber genau so ist es gelaufen. Und das finde ich persönlich schon erschreckend, dass da letztlich dann mehr oder weniger ein Mensch, der da diesen Gesetzentwurf verantwortet hat, da was durchboxen kann. Und da offensichtlich selbst in einem so großen und so kompetenten Haus wie dem Justizministerium niemand mehr drüberguckt und das mal nochmal durchdenkt.
Ist das Arbeitsvolumen, ist das böser Wille, wollte man das jetzt so durchboxen, weil man eigentlich eine andere Agenda hat oder ist das wirklich einfach, ey, das muss jetzt fertig werden und deswegen hauen wir das jetzt hoch aus?
Also ich finde es immer ganz schwierig, so eine böse Agenda zu unterstellen. Ich glaube, der eigentliche Grund ist, dass man dieses Gesetz unbedingt huckepack mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung durch den Bundestag schmuggeln wollte, damit darüber nicht zu viel diskutiert wird. Und dieses huckepack setzt da halt voraus, dass der Gesetzentwurf, dieser Teil Datenhehlerei, quasi auch schon fertig ist, wenn der Rest fertig ist. Man konnte quasi nicht auf die Datenhehlerei warten. Und die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ein Prestigeprojekt gewesen der alten Großen Koalition. Das musste also schnell durch den Bundestag. Ich glaube, man hat deswegen einfach die Einwände nicht so wirklich ernsthaft geprüft, weil man das Gesetz zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht aufhalten wollte. Ich schätze, dass das der politische Grund ist. Das kann ich aber nicht nachweisen. Also das lässt sich in den Akten nicht dokumentieren. Man sieht nur, da ist eine Vermutung, muss ich so deutlich so kennzeichnen. Aber das liegt nahe vom Zeitablauf her, dass man halt einfach nicht warten wollte, bis man die Datenhelerei quasi wirklich sauber formuliert hat, damit das Gesamtprojekt Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht irgendwie gebremst wird.
Also wenn es stimmt, dann kann man subsumieren, dass es manchmal ganz banal ist, warum Gesetze auf den Weg gebracht werden, die einfach nicht gut sind. Und die wahrscheinlich der Gesetzgeber auch so gar nicht wollte. Oder? Kann man das da sagen an der Stelle? Dass es nicht im Interesse des Gesetzgebers ist, Whistleblower sozusagen, als Auffallprodukt über diesen...
Ich hoffe das einfach mal. Ich wage da letztlich keine Interpretation, wie das zum Beispiel Heiko Maas sieht. Also er hat sich im Bundestag hingestellt bei der Verabschiedung des Gesetzes und hat ziemlich geschimpft über die Kritik von Seiten der Presse. Oder auch zum Beispiel meine Kritik, weil er sagt, es ist völliger Unsinn, die Presse ist gut geschützt und so. Aber es ist schwer einzuschätzen, ob er das geglaubt hat, was er da gesagt hat. Er hat also ziemlich auf die Brust geklopft. Aber ob er das wirklich glaubt, das weiß ich nicht.
Wir reden über Freiheitsrechte. Jetzt gerade über das Anti-Whistleblower-Gesetz. So wird es zumindest umschrieben in einschlägigen Blogs. Die Rede ist von Datenhehlereiparagrafen. Wir haben gleich noch eine halbe Stunde Chaosradio mit Ulf Burmeier von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Da werden wir über das Polizeiaufgabengesetz sprechen. Und dann hat uns noch eine Frage über das Telefoning erreicht. Da geht es ums Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Und da geht es um einen internationalen Vergleich davon. Denn wir haben das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz noch nicht so lange. Es gibt viele andere Länder, die etwas Ähnliches haben. Die USA beispielsweise, Freedom of Information Act. Und die Schweden haben offensichtlich auch ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Und danach wird gefragt. Mal gespannt, ob Ulf darauf antworten kann. Wir hören uns gleich wieder nach den Nachrichten und den Nerd-News. Vorher noch Kaltestadt von Lena Störfaktor.
Heimlich, still und leise gegen Nazis sein kann jeder. Aber laut gegen Nazis zu sein, dazu gehört Mut. Und genau deshalb präsentiert Fritz.
Laut gegen Nazis.
Das Campus Open Air der BTU-Konfus Senftenberg. Und laut und gegen Nazis auf der Bühne die BeatStates. Und die Leoniden. Open Air auf dem Campus Gelände der BTU-Konfus Senftenberg. Der Eintritt kostet keinen Eintritt. Und kommen kann jeder, der tolerant ist gegenüber Menschen, die anders aussehen, reden, glauben oder lieben.
Siedsänger Demba Nabe ist im Alter von 46 Jahren gestorben. Er war einer der drei Frontmänner der Berliner Band. Nabezai hatte morgen gestorben, teilte der Anwalt von Sied mit. Die Todesursache ist bislang nicht bekannt. Von Nabez Bandkollegen hieß es, die Band trauere um ihren Freund. Erst vor einem Monat hatte Sied eine Tour für den Herbst 2019 angekündigt. In Italien steht nach wochenlangen Verhandlungen eine neue Regierung. Präsident Mattarella erteilte dem parteilosen Juristen Conte den Regierungsauftrag, sagte ein Sprecher. Die Vereidigung soll morgen in Rom stattfinden. Conte wird von der populistischen Fünf-Sterne-Bewegung und der rechten Liga unterstützt. Ein erster Anlauf zur Regierungsbildung war gescheitert, nachdem Mattarella eine Euro-kritischen Kandidaten für einen Ministerposten abgelehnt hatte. Die Bundesregierung hält die von den USA verhängten Zölle auf Stahl- und Aluminium-Importe für rechtswidrig. Regierungsprecher Seibert erklärte, die von den USA angeführten Gründe der nationalen Sicherheit seien nicht ausreichend. EU-Kommissionspräsident Juncker kündigte in Brüssel an, Beschwerde bei der Welthandelsorganisation gegen die US-Zölle einzulegen. Die EU werde außerdem umgehend Gegenmaßnahmen einleiten und ihrerseits Zölle erheben. Die US-Regierung hatte zuvor bekanntgegeben, dass die seit Ende März geltenden Ausnahmeregelungen für die EU nicht verlängert werden. Das Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus hat ein neues Landesdatenschutzgesetz beschlossen. Damit soll die aktuelle EU-Richtlinie zum Datenschutz umgesetzt werden. Berlins Datenschutzbeauftragter kritisierte das Gesetz aber, Berlin würde Auskunftsrechte einschränken und ganze Bereiche, wie z.B. der Rechnungshof, seien von der datenschutzrechtlichen Kontrolle ausgenommen. Durch die neue EU-Verordnung können Bürger besser nachverfolgen, was mit ihren Daten geschieht. Die aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin Mitte 26°, Atlashof 27°, Karlau 21°, Cottbus und Bad Freienwalde 23°, Brandenburg an der Hafe 24°. Leichte Wolken und größtenteils trocken, so wird die Nacht. Nur im Süden und Westen kann es einzelne Schauer und Gewitter geben. Die Tiefstwerte liegen bei 15 bis 20°. Der Tag startet dann mit viel Sonne, im Verlauf bilden sich dann aber auch Quellwolken, die teils kräftige Schauer und Gewitter mitbringen. Dazu wird es sehr warm, mit 30 bis 34°. Und so bleibt es auch in den nächsten Tagen schwül und heiß mit Gewittern zwischendurch. Stadtverkehr Berlin B96, Oranienburger Chaussee zwischen Schwarz-Kittelweg in Frohnau und Berliner Stadtgrenze, Vollsperrung in beiden Richtungen wegen Fahrbahnanäuerung bis morgen früh um 6 und auf der A113 Zubringer Schönefeld statt einwärts, Sperrung zwischen Schönefeld Süd- und Adlershof wegen Wartungsarbeiten. Wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt.
Und weil das hier Chaosradio ist, kommen die Nerd-News gleich hinterher, ebenfalls gelesen von Bene Wenck.
Viele E-Mail-Programme setzen Verschlüsselungsstandards fehlerhaft um. Viele bekannte und beliebte E-Mail-Programme setzen die Verschlüsselungsstandard S-MIME und PGP fehlerhaft um. Forschern von der Fachhochschule Münster tauften das von ihnen gefundene Problem E-Fail. Es handele sich um eine Kombination aus fehlerhafter Umsetzung der Standards und unsicheren Standardeinstellungen. Sicherheitsexperten empfehlen, im E-Mail-Programm auf HTML verzichten, das Nachladen von externen Inhalten deaktivieren und die betroffenen Verschlüsselungsplugins aktualisieren. Die humanistische Union, das Forum InformatikerInnen für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung und weitere Organisationen haben den Grundrechte-Report veröffentlicht. Sie wollen damit die Aufmerksamkeit auf die eigentlichen Gefährdungen für den Rechtsstaat und die Grundrechte lenken. Diese gingen nach ihrer Ansicht vom Staat und seinen Institutionen selbst aus. Die offiziellen Verfassungsschutzberichte von Bund und Ländern schilderten lediglich die angeblichen Gefährdungen der freiheitlich-demokratischen Grundordnung. Allerdings hätten sie zu keinem Zeitpunkt die Bundesrepublik ernsthaft in Gefahr bringen können. Der alternative Verfassungsschutzbericht lege dagegen einen Schwerpunkt auf die wahren Einschränkungen von Freiheitsrechten und die überbordende Überwachung. Google hat angekündigt, mit HTTPS überschlüsselter Seiten in seinem Browser Chrome nicht mehr gesondert als gesichert zu markieren. Auch das berühmte Vorhängeschloss hat ausgedient. Stattdessen soll Chrome vor unverschlüsselten Seiten warnen. Benutzer sollten erwarten, dass das Web im Normalfall sicher ist, so die Entwickler. Motillas Browser Firefox beschreitet bereits einen ähnlichen Pfad und warnt, sobald Daten an unverschlüsselt aufgerufene Seiten gesendet werden. In den letzten Jahren ist die Anzahl der unverschlüsselten, übertragenden Seiten im Internet dank Initiativen wie Let's Encrypt stark geschrumpft.
Das waren die Nerd-News mit reingestreuten Stolperstellen hier für Bene Wenk in der Ausgabe Chaosradio 246 um 23 Uhr und jetzt 37 Minuten.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Rbb.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt Oder diesen Sound Dann hört doch mal im Club Immer samstags ab 20 Uhr und im Radio. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de slash Musik Streams. Tschüss!
Chaosradio 246 anwesend, Danimo und nach wie vor Ulf Burmeier. Ihr kennt ihn möglicherweise vom Podcast Lage der Nation. Hier ist er in seiner gesellschaftsrelevanten zweiten Funktion da, nämlich als Gründer und Vorsitzender von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Diese Gesellschaft sucht sich Fälle, mit denen sie unser aller Freiheit sozusagen verteidigen kann, vor allen Dingen vor dem deutschen Gesetzgeber, dass das beispielsweise beim Datenheilereiparagraphen notwendig ist, wie auch beim BND-Gesetz. Das haben wir in den vergangenen Minuten und Stunden schon diskutiert. Jetzt wird es gleich gehen um ein interessantes Gesetz namens Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, das es in Deutschland so ungefähr, glaube ich, seit 2005 gibt, das allerdings noch Wünsche offen lässt. Aber man kann darüber schon viele Informationen einholen. Manche werden allerdings dann nicht gewährt. Und das sind dann Fälle, die wieder bei der GFF landen, wo sie sich darum kümmert, dass Auskünfte aus deutschen Behörden dann eben doch erteilt werden. Ulf, das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, du bist Fan, ne?
Ich bin grundsätzlich ein Fan des IFG. Ich finde, es könnte ein paar weniger Ausnahmen enthalten. Was sind denn da so Ausnahmen? Es gibt relativ weitgehende Möglichkeiten, bestimmte Informationen aus Behördenakten doch nicht rauszugeben. Ein Klassiker sind zum Beispiel Geschäftsgeheimnisse. Wenn Firmen sich beispielsweise bei einer Ausschreibung bewerben, dann kann man grundsätzlich nicht mit einer IFG-Anfrage mal so herausfinden, was zum Beispiel die Mitbewerber so angeboten haben. Das macht während der Laufenden Ausschreibung Sinn. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ein, zwei Jahre später wäre es doch schon mal interessant zu sehen, wie denn da eigentlich der Markt so aussah. Da kann man ja auch nicht mehr wirklich von Geschäftsgeheimnissen reden. Trotzdem müssen dann immer noch die Firmen gefragt werden, ob sie einverstanden sind. Normalerweise sind sie natürlich nicht einverstanden. Diese Dinge offen zu legen. Das ist so ein Klassiker. Und natürlich gibt es auch Ausnahmen, z.B. in manchen Bundesländern, die ausgesprochen problematisch sind. Das ist ein Fall, wo wir sagen müssen, da hat die GFF vor Gericht mal verloren.
Alle denken hier so, Bayern.
Aber in diesem Fall ist es das beschauliche Rheinland-Pfalz, das nämlich seit einiger Zeit ein neues sogenanntes Transparenzgesetz hat. Das aber in einem interessanten Punkt eher ein Intransparenzgesetz ist. Nämlich, da ist der gesamte Bereich der Drittmittelforschung an Universitäten ausgeklammert aus der Informationsfreiheit. Ich kann also eine Universität nicht fragen, welches Industrieunternehmen zum Beispiel einem Professor Millionen dafür zahlt, dass er, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Mitarbeiter einstellen kann. Und deswegen kann man dann eben nicht so richtig prüfen, welche inhaltlichen Vorgaben dieses Unternehmen möglicherweise gemacht hat für Forschung und Lehre. Und das zum Beispiel finde ich ausgesprochen bedenklich. Ich finde es ja wunderbar, wenn quasi Wissenschaft und Praxis zusammenfinden. Aber ich wüsste schon gerne, auf welche Art und Weise die Industrie dann mit ihrem Geld Einfluss darauf nimmt, was die theoretisch freie Wissenschaft so tut.
Interessante Auslassungen bei diesem Gesetz. Tatsächlich muss ich ausdustimmen.
Es gibt eine Sparre.
Richtig. Was sind denn die Menschen, die zu euch kommen, deren Begehren abgeschmettert wurde beispielsweise? Ihr habt ja einige Transparenzklagen, glaube ich.
Ja, wir haben quasi ein Programm Transparenzklagen. Häufig, nicht immer, häufig in Zusammenarbeit mit Frag den Staat. Ja, Frag den Staat ist ja eine Internetplattform, wo man relativ einfach Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfragen stellen kann an Behörden. Diese Plattform stellt einem so Fragen, das heißt, sie ermöglicht es einem da besonders gut, besonders einfach, richtige Anfragen zu stellen.
Was ja auch ein bisschen kompliziert ist dann wahrscheinlich.
Ja, es gibt da halt so eine Reihe von Textbausteinen, die man am besten reinbauen sollte und die gibt einem Frag den Staat einfach sehr gut vor. Das ist jetzt keine Raketenwissenschaft, aber es macht schon Sinn, das über Frag den Staat zu machen, denn dann macht man einfach bestimmte Fehler nicht. Und wenn man da aber keinen Erfolg hat, wenn also diese Anfrage abgelehnt wird, dann kann man sich bei uns bewerben um eine sogenannte Transparenzpatenschaft. Und wenn wir sagen, dieser Fall ist ein Fall für die GFF, dann bezahlen wir quasi die Gerichtskosten vor dem Verwaltungsgericht erst mal in der ersten Instanz und auch die Anwaltskosten. Das heißt also dann kann man als Bürgerin oder als Bürger kostenfrei die Behörde versuchen zu zwingen, dass sie diese Informationen eben doch herausgibt.
Was sind denn das für Informationen, die da gewünscht werden von Bürgern? Das ist ja offenbar angenommen worden, es werden Anfragen gestellt.
Ja, eine ganze Reihe. Es ist ein ganz ganz buntes Feld. Wir haben zum Beispiel eine Anfrage, da geht es um Protokolle der Bundesregierung und zwar aus den entscheidenden Sitzungen, als das Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverlage beschlossen wurde. Hier will ich jetzt gar nichts detailgen, aber jedenfalls ein sehr umstrittenes Gesetz, das maßgeblich gefordert wurde von Lobbyisten aus dem Springer Verlag. Und damals war es so, dass einer von zwei Brüdern beim Springer Verlag beschäftigt war und der andere in hoher Funktion in der Bundesregierung. Und da wollte einfach ein Journalist gerne wissen, ob denn zufälligerweise bei der entscheidenden Sitzung dieser Bruder, des Springer Lobbyisten, auch dabei war. Das wäre eine interessante Frage gewesen. Und das will die Bundesregierung eben nicht rausrücken. Dieses Protokoll bekommt er nicht und das ist einer der Fälle. Natürlich kann man jetzt sagen, das ist vielleicht nicht der, wie soll ich sagen, das ist keine ganz zentrale Frage für den Bestand unseres Staates, aber es stellen sich einfach sehr interessante Rechtsfragen, gerade so aus der Perspektive, was darf man denn so alles ablehnen? Es gibt ja sowas wie einen geschützten Kernbereich der exekutiven Meinungsbildung, wo die Bundesregierung sich quasi nicht in die Karten gucken lassen muss und in dem Verfahren geht es unter anderem darum, wie weit reicht quasi so dieser Geheimbereich, wo die Bundesregierung sich im Geheimen eine Meinung bilden kann.
Behandelt ihr eigentlich auch Fälle, wo Behörden exorbitante Gebühren für Auskünfte verlangt haben oder lässt sich das meistens anders regeln?
Das war kein Fall, den wir durchgeklagt haben, sondern ich glaube, der war von Korrektiv. Ich bin völlig täuscht, es ist so, dass es einen bestimmten Gebührendeckel gibt bei der Bearbeitung von solchen Anfragen nach dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Wenn man aber natürlich eine Frage quasi willkürlich stückelt als Behörde und sagt, also diese eine Anfrage betrifft aber 500 Aktenordner und dann erhebt man die Gebühr für jeden Aktenordner einzeln, die Höchstgebühr, dann kann es mit einmal sehr, sehr teuer werden und deswegen hatte ich meinen, es war Korrektiv. Bin ich ganz sicher hat Korrektiv, glaube ich, mal geklagt und haben dann auch gewonnen. Das war also kein Fall der GFF. Jedenfalls ist jetzt klar, man darf als Behörde eine einzelne Anfrage nicht willkürlich stuckeln, sondern eine Anfrage ist tatsächlich im Prinzip auch eine Anfrage.
Jetzt haben wir auch eine Anfrage und zwar von Josef. Hallo Josef. Du hast eine sehr expertige Frage und zwar fragst du hier zumindest, ist das das, was beim Redakteur angekommen ist und bei mir, was denn Ulf, nehme ich mal an vor allen Dingen vom schwedischen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz handelt. Jetzt haben wir hier intern schon gesprochen, Ulf kennt das schwedische Freiheitsinformationsgesetz nicht, Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Aber vielleicht können wir dich fragen, Josef, welchen Punkt du da meinst? Ja, Schweden ist ja quasi die Mutter aller Freiheitsgesetze. Das nennt sich da Öffentlichkeitsprinzip. Das ist das Recht bei Behörden und Ämtern in alle Akten und Dokumente Einsicht nehmen zu können. Das bedeutet, dass alle in einer Behörde vorhandenen Akten und Dokumente einschließlich Bandaufnahmen und computergespeicherte Daten für die Allgemeinheit zugänglich sind. Und dieses Recht besteht schon in Schweden seit 1766.
Die USA zum Beispiel haben ihren Freedom of Information Act erst 1966 beschlossen.
200 Jahre später, und wir haben dann nochmal 50 Jahre in Deutschland abgewartet, dass unser Informationsfreiheitsgesetz im Vergleich zu Schweden sehr intransparent ist. Weil zum Beispiel in Schweden gehen sie ja so weit, dass auch alle Steuererklärungen offen, öffentlich sind.
Genau, da wollte ich gerade hin. Um Korruption zu verhindern zum Beispiel.
Ja, also das heißt, es geht noch immer besser. Wo siehst du denn Ulf, die Verbesserungen beim Informationsfreiheitsgesetz? Also wenn du das jetzt so hörst, Schweden, das muss man wahrscheinlich einschränken. Die werden auch irgendwelche Staatsgeheimnisse haben, nachdem man dann eben nicht fragen kann. Tippe ich mal, keine Ahnung. Aber wo würdest du den ansetzen beim deutschen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, um zu sagen, da muss man ran?
Also ich habe ja eben schon den Punkt genannt, Geschäftsgeheimnisse. Das ist eben sehr häufig ein Trick, wie Behörden eben doch viele Informationen dann nicht rausrücken. Das ist auch zum Beispiel ein Thema jetzt bei dem besonderen elektronischen Anwaltspostfach. Das ist ja so eine der aktuellen Skandale, die jemand aus dem CCC aufgedeckt hat. Massive Sicherheitslücken bei dem bald obligatorischen Mittel der Anwaltskommunikation in Deutschland. Auch da ist es so, dass wesentliche Informationen eben nicht an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, weil die beteiligten Firmen sagen, nein, das sind unsere Geschäftsgeheimnisse. Und da muss man denke ich sagen, bislang haben da solche Geschäftsgeheimnisse eine extrem starke Stellung. Und ich denke, das wird eine der politischen Aufgaben der nächsten Jahre sein, die einfach mindestens sowas wie eine Abwägung einzuführen, dass also Geschäftsgeheimnisse nicht quasi wie ein Trumpf alle anderen Argumente stechen, sondern dass sie nur abgewogen werden müssen mit zum Beispiel dem Interesse der Öffentlichkeit. Und ein weiterer wichtiger Punkt wäre aus meiner Sicht so eine Art Sunset-Klausel, dass Geschäftsgeheimnisse eben nicht bis in alle Ewigkeit Geschäftsgeheimnisse bleiben, sondern dass man sagt, okay, die mögen heute geschützt sein, aber ich hatte das Beispiel mit den Ausschreibungen ja eben schon gebracht. Jedenfalls nach einigen Jahren ist die Kalkulation in einer Ausschreibung oder bei einer Bewerbung für eine Ausschreibung einfach nicht mehr schutzwürdig. Dass man halt sagt, Geschäftsgeheimnis ist jedenfalls nach drei Jahren oder nach fünf Jahren je nach den Umständen nicht mehr schutzwürdig. Das sind so Themen, an denen man, denke ich, arbeiten kann. Dann gibt es natürlich ganze Bereichsausnahmen für Behörden wie den Bundesnachrichtendienst oder manche Rechnungshöfe, die völlig ausgeklammert sind. Da kann man sich auch die Frage stellen, wie viel Sinn macht das? Da hat jemand mal, vielleicht auch so halbscherzhaft, nach dem Speiseplan der Kantine des BND gefragt. Und auch da wurde gesagt, nö, BND gibt es nicht. Wo man sich schon fragen kann, warum ist dieser Speiseplan top secret?
Hältst du so was für machbar, so ein umfassendes Gesetz, wie das offenbar in Schweden zu sein scheint?
Also ich denke, dass es einfach wirklich ein Kulturwandel ist, den wir so langsam aber sicher sehen in den Behörden, der aber eben noch nicht abgeschlossen ist. Und es gibt eben auch eine Gegenbewegung. Es gibt eben inzwischen auch schon den Effekt, dass viele Informationen einfach gar nicht mehr zu den Akten gegeben werden, sondern zum Beispiel per E-Mail ausgetauscht, nicht ausgedruckt werden oder nur in irgendwelchen schwarzen Akten parallel geführt werden, die dann gar nicht zum Bestandteil der offiziellen Akten werden. Das kann man manchmal sogar nachweisen, wenn man also Unterlagen bekommt bei einer IFG-Anfrage, wo Bezug genommen wird auf andere Unterlagen, die offensichtlich nicht Bestandteil der Akte geworden sind. Das ist, muss man sagen, eine deutliche Umgehung der Informationsfreiheit, wenn Behörden parallel Akten führen oder schwarze Akten führen, die dann eben nicht rausgegeben werden. Ich hoffe, dass das nicht der Standardfall ist, aber das sieht man. Und deswegen spreche ich von einem Kulturwandel. Das wird man nicht nur mit Gesetzen erreichen können, sondern das ist auch einfach eine Frage der Überzeugungsarbeit in den Behörden. Da muss man die Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter mitnehmen und ihnen einfach sagen, das ist gut, wenn die Menschen hier sehen, was ihr tut. Das ist gut, denn zum einen haben sie es bezahlt, ganz banal. Öffentliche Gelder sollten auch zu öffentlichen Daten führen. Das ist das eine. Und zum anderen dient es aber natürlich auch der Vertrauensbildung. Wenn ich also schauen kann, was eigentlich eine Behörde so tut, dann habe ich unter Umständen ein viel größeres Vertrauen darin, dass die Behörde nach Recht und Gesetz arbeitet. Und davon gehe ich einfach aus, dass das das Ziel aller Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter ist, dass sie sich selbstverständlich versuchen, an das Recht zu halten.
Ich habe noch eine kurze Anmerkung, darf ich? Ja, natürlich.
Zum Thema Post, das ist doch auch eine Sache, die eigentlich auch komplett unsicher ist.
In den USA werden schon seit etlichen Jahren der komplette Briefverkehr gespeichert. Das heißt, wer, wem, wo und wie Post schickt. Es ist in den USA offiziell bekannt, dass die Post jeden Brief einscannt und speichert, wer wie kommuniziert hat, um eventuelle Terroranschläge zu verhindern. Auch die deutsche Post speichert Adressen angeblich nur für drei Tage.
Ob das stimmt, weiß man nicht.
Mit den drei Tagen, da fies einscannt, wurde schon offiziell zugegeben. Und dann noch eine andere Anmerkung.
Früher in der DDR wurden die Briefe mit Heißdampf und so aufgemacht.
Das braucht man ja heute auch nicht mehr machen. Es gibt Techniken mit Terrorherzstrahlung, wo ich geschlossene Bücher lesen kann. Über mehrere Seiten dicke.
Also 30 Seiten sind mir aktuell bekannt, dass die Technik so weit ist. Dass ich ein komplett geschlossenes Buch lesen kann.
Und das ist jetzt erst dann schon zwei Jahre alt.
Das heißt, es wird wahrscheinlich schon mehr möglich sein, an geschlossene Informationen in Büchern oder Unterlagen zu kommen, ohne sie äußerlich nur anfassen zu müssen.
Also das heißt, wenn wir vorhin davon gesprochen haben, Dokumente schriftlich einzureichen, ist es möglicherweise auch nicht unbedingt sinnvoll. Josef, ich verstehe das mal so als Eingabe. Wir wollten gleich noch ein bisschen über das Polizeiaufgabengesetz sprechen. Wir haben nur noch zehn Minuten. Am Ende drückt der Schuh natürlich immer. Ich danke dir vielmals für den Anruf, Josef. Bis dann, tschau. Ja, hier war so ein stilles Knop. Kopfnicken bei der Terra-Strahlung. Danimo, schon mal untergekommen, sowas?
Ja, Terraherzscanner sind ja auch das, was man mittlerweile an den Flughäfen hat.
Mit Armen hoch, wo die Schweißflecken immer rauskommen.
Genau, das ist im Prinzip, das dürfte im Prinzip das gleiche Verfahren sein. Auch da geht es bis knapp unter die Haut, wenn er jetzt sagt 30 Seiten. Ich stecke in dem Thema jetzt selber auch nicht genau drin, aber es wäre zumindest vorstellbar, dass generell Metadaten, also auch im Brief verkehren, irgendwie eine Form gespeichert werden. Die Maschinen können das, das weiß ich. Inwieweit es da gesetzliche Grundlagen für gibt, bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher.
Also nicht besorgniserregend, Ulf?
Ja, das ist in der Tat keine Neuigkeit, dass Briefe abfotografiert werden, dass quasi die Empfänger- und die Absenderanschriften gespeichert werden. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wer das konkret macht und auf welcher Grundlage, aber ich weiß, dass das tatsächlich schon passiert. Deswegen, wenn man eben Dinge an einen Journalisten schickt, sollte man natürlich keinen Absender draufschreiben. Das versteht sich von selber. Oder wenn überhaupt, sollte man das in den Brief schreiben, wenn man sehr mutig ist.
Okay, wir reden noch ganz kurz. Die wenigen verbleibenden Minuten über das Polizeiaufgabengesetz hat immerhin geschafft, obwohl es auch nicht weniger kompliziert ist, als die Dinge, über die wir uns jetzt hier gerade unterhalten haben, 30.000 Menschen auf die Straße zu bringen. Die alle aufgebracht waren in München, weil möglicherweise so Dinge möglich sind wie Polizisten, die Handgranaten tragen. Und was war noch drin? Dass man das Durchsuchen und Verändern von Daten, beispielsweise der Polizei, erlaubte. Und vor allen Dingen, dass man sozusagen den Einsatzmoment der Polizei herabverringert auf eine drohende Gefahr. Das heißt, sie muss nicht mehr abwarten, bis eine konkrete Gefahr vorliegt, sondern sie kann schon vorgehen und ermitteln und möglicherweise ausspionieren, wenn nur eine Gefahr droht. Und das klingt sehr schwammig. Die Handgranaten, Ulf, habe ich gelesen, sind eine Legende.
Die Handgranaten sollen nämlich schon vorher zulässig gewesen sein. So viel zum Thema Bayern. Ich meine mal ganz ehrlich, alle Kriminalstatistiken weisen ja aus, dass Deutschland insgesamt, nicht nur der Freistaat Bayern, Jahr für Jahr sicherer wird. Wir haben immer weniger, jedenfalls der Polizei, bekannt gewordene Straftaten. Insofern kann man sich schon mal ganz generell die Frage stellen, warum eigentlich muss ein Polizeigesetz massiv nachgeschärft werden, wenn doch ganz offensichtlich die Lage eigentlich gar nicht so wahnsinnig problematisch ist.
Erneuert werden müssen sie immer. Das war jetzt dem vorausgegangen das BKA-Gesetz oder so. Und deswegen müssen sie angepasst werden, oder um neue Datenschutzverordnungen damit einzupassen. Deswegen musste das novelliert werden. Und in dem Zuge, so wie ich es verstanden habe, hat Bayern gesagt, dann schreiben wir noch ein paar andere Sachen mit rein.
Da hätte man halt, wenn man es gewollt hätte, auch einfach nur quasi die Datenschutzregeln und ein paar Informationsregeln ändern können. Nein, man hat dann eben auf breiter Front die Möglichkeiten der Polizei erweitert. Und diese Einzelmaßnahmen finde ich persönlich gar nicht das wirklich Problematische an dem Gesetz, sondern das Problematische ist aus meiner Sicht und auch aus Sicht der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte dieses Schlagwort der drohenden Gefahr. Dazu muss man wissen, dass die Polizei ja zuständig ist für die Gefahrenabwehr. Also jedenfalls, wenn wir jetzt vom Polizeiaufgabengesetz sprechen, geht es nicht um die Bekämpfung von Straftaten. Das geht nach anderen Gesetzen, vor allem nach der Strafprozessordnung, sondern hier sind wir nur im Bereich des sogenannten präventiven Handelns, also wo die Polizei versucht zu verhindern, dass irgendwas schiefgeht. Dass also ein Schaden eintritt für ein Rechtsgut, dass jemand verletzt wird, das Eigentum beschädigt wird, dass schlimmstenfalls jemand stirbt. Das Prävention, Verhinderung des Eintritts von Schäden ist der Gegenstand des Polizeiaufgabengesetzes. Und da war es bislang eben so, dass die Polizei nur in Bürgerrechte eingreifen durfte, in Fällen einer konkreten Gefahr. Das heißt also, wenn unmittelbar eine Situation bestand, wenn man also quasi Tatsachen festnageln konnte, bei denen zu befürchten war, dass jetzt bald, wenn es so weitergeht, wenn sich eine Situation weiterentwickelt, ein Schaden eintritt. Und diese Voraussetzung, die war natürlich relativ eng. Das konnte man immer noch annehmen. Die Polizei hat natürlich immer schon einen Einschätzungsspielraum gehabt. Reicht uns das jetzt an Gefahr, ja oder nein? Aber das war jedenfalls etwas, was man notfalls auch noch gerichtlich kontrollieren konnte. Und bei der drohenden Gefahr wird das jetzt weitaus abstrakter gefasst. Das heißt also, die Polizei bekommt einen wesentlich größeren Spielraum bei der Einschätzung. Denn es muss eben keine konkrete Gefahr mehr sein, sondern es muss nur drohen. Es muss eine Situation sein, die dazu führen könnte, dass es irgendwann wahrscheinlich wird, dass ein Schaden eintritt. Also quasi ein Level an Indirection mehr. Eine Ebene von Präzision weniger. Und das bedeutet in der Praxis, dass man einfach nicht mehr gerichtlich prüfen kann, ob die Polizei richtig gehandelt hat oder nicht. Das ist das eigentliche Problem dabei. Also zum einen wird die Polizei nicht mehr angehalten, wirklich zu prüfen, brennt hier gleich was an, ja oder nein, sondern sie kann weit im Vorfeld tätig werden. Und zum zweiten kann man hinterher auch, also man kann natürlich immer noch hingehen zum Gericht, aber das Gericht hat kaum jemals die Möglichkeit festzustellen, hier lag eine Situation vor, in der völlig ausgeschlossen war, dass es mal richtig brenzlig werden könnte.
Deswegen ist es von deiner Warte aus schon gerechtfertigt, dass da so viele Leute auf dem Platz standen und dagegen demonstriert haben, nehme ich mal an. Es wird jetzt aber so umgesetzt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, oder ist schon so weit, oder lässt sich dann noch was machen?
Also das Gesetz ist jedenfalls vom Landtag in Bayern beschlossen und es ist auch in Kraft getreten, soweit ich weiß. Ich meine, vor ein paar Jahren ist auch in Kraft getreten, jedenfalls verkündet ist es schon im Gesetzblatt für den Freistaat Bayern. Aber das ist natürlich nicht das letzte Wort, die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte hat ein Crowdfunding gemacht, um eine Klage zu finanzieren, eine Verfassungsbeschwerde von dem Bundesverfassungsgericht gegen dieses neue Bayerische Polizeiaufgabengesetz. Und dabei wird der Begriff der drohenden Gefahr eine ganz zentrale Rolle spielen. Das Crowdfunding war auch relativ erfolgreich. Wir haben nicht ganz die Fundingschwelle erreicht, sind aber sehr zuversichtlich, dass das gelingen kann. Und wir versuchen da zur Zeit eine Zusammenarbeit zu organisieren mit dem Bayerischen NoPak-Bündnis. Das ist also ein Bündnis von inzwischen über 90 Organisationen aus der Zivilgesellschaft. Auch die meisten Parteien sind da mit dabei, außer der CSU natürlich. Und wir wollen versuchen, mit diesem breiten gesellschaftlichen Bündnis gemeinsam und vermutlich auch mit einem Anwalt aus München zusammen gegen dieses Gesetz nach Karlsruhe zu ziehen.
Und damit sind wir auch am entscheidenden Punkt hier kurz vor Ende dieser Sendung. Die GFF finanziert sich natürlich über Spenden und das möglicherweise auch über eure. Ihr habt einen Spendenbutton auf der Seite freiheitsrechte.org, wenn euch die Arbeit der GFF gefällt und ihr sie wichtig findet, dann könnt ihr dorthin gehen. Wie finanziert ihr euch ansonsten nur über diese Spenden oder diese Crowdfunding-Deals, die ihr da macht für konkrete Geschichten? Oder gibt es auch sozusagen so Big Donors, die im Hintergrund stehen und sagen, ich gebe Geld dafür, dass das ordentlich läuft?
Also wir finanzieren uns am allerliebsten über kleine Spenden und über Fördermitgliedschaften. Das ist unser allerliebstes. Also Menschen, die sagen, ich unterstütze die GFF jedes Jahr mit einem bestimmten Beitrag. Das ist das Allerschönste, weil es uns einfach eine gewisse Planungssicherheit ermöglicht, dass man also auch Menschen einstellen kann. Wir wollen ja jetzt nicht hire and fire mäßig Leute einstellen und nach einem Jahr sie wieder rausschmeißen, weil das Geld alle ist. Deswegen sind die Fördermitgliedschaften besonders klasse. Ansonsten haben wir inzwischen viele tausend Menschen, die mit kleinen und größeren Spenden die Arbeit der GFF ermöglichen. Dafür sind wir sehr, sehr dankbar. Wir haben aber auch einige wenige größere Spende, aber der Anteil der Einzelspenden und der Fördermitgliedschaften liegt bei deutlich über 50 Prozent. Ich glaube, es sind so zwischen 60 und 70 Prozent, die von kleineren Geldgebern stammen. Und das finden wir sehr, sehr schön, weil wir dann einfach nicht von einzelnen Zuwendungen abhängig sind, sondern dann kann also tatsächlich die GFF eigenverantwortlich ihre Prioritäten festlegen. Und wir müssen jetzt nicht darauf Rücksicht nehmen, dass irgendein großer Spender sagt, klagt doch mal hier gegen oder viel schlimmer noch, klagt mal nicht dagegen.
Wir haben über Freiheitsrechte gesprochen hier im Chaosradio 246, wo ich ausnahmsweise eingesprungen bin für den lieben Kollegen Markus Richter, der verhindert war. Danimo sieht es mir noch gegenüber. Am Ende, Danimo, dann sagt ihr doch bestimmt noch irgendwelche Links durch oder man kann hier noch was hören oder klicken oder sowas, dass ich alles immer nicht weiß.
Achso, nee, jetzt erstmal nichts Konkretes. Auf jeden Fall könnt ihr diese Sendung nachhören unter Chaosradio CCCDE in den nächsten Tagen. Das Video wird es dann auch auf MediaCCCDE geben. Und ich kann euch auch nur noch mal empfehlen, Fördermitglied, GFF habe ich gemacht, finde ich wichtig, macht das auch.
Fühlt sich gut an. Ich bedanke mich beim Chaosradio, dass sie mich hier ausgehalten haben. Es hat geruckelt und gewackelt ein wenig. Ich bitte, das zu entschuldigen, auch beim Podcast. Es wird nicht rausgeschnitten, sondern bleibt für alle Ewigkeit erhalten. Ich bedanke mich bei Ulf Burmeier, der hier für uns da war und zwei Stunden Expertise gegeben hat über die GFF und vor allen Dingen natürlich auch über Freiheitsrechte und wie man sie verteidigt und natürlich auch der Kollege Nora Markath, die uns über Skype zugeschaltet war, ebenfalls von der GFF. Vielen Dank und machts gut. Bis dann, tschüss.